hi guys welcome to this complete
blockchain tutorial by simply learn my
name is sandeep and in the next few
hours we'll be teaching you everything
you need to know about blockchain
guiding you on this learning journey is
saurav our industry expert with over
five years of experience in the field of
blockchain bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies
first off we'll go through a short
animated introduction to blockchain
followed by a tutorial on how blockchain
works
we'll then teach you about what a
cryptocurrency is and the different
types of cryptocurrencies in the market
available to you
next we'll teach you about ethereum and
how smart contracts work then you will
learn about the process of bitcoin
mining and how bitcoin wallets work
after that we look into how ethereum and
bitcoin are different from each other
then we will tell you about the five
industries blockchain will disrupt
followed by 10 things you probably
didn't know about bitcoin
we will then talk about some of the
popular applications of blockchain and
how you can become a blockchain
developer and finally we have handpicked
30 of the most important questions you
might face in a blockchain interview
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to our channel and click on the bell
icon to never miss an update from simply
learn with that out of the way let's
look at our animated video ever wonder
if there's an easier way to complete
transactions without having to deal with
online wallets banks and third-party
applications well it's possible thanks
to blockchain here's everything you need
to know about blockchain imagine four
friends jack ted sam and phil meet up
for dinner after they're done jack pays
the bill and all of them decide to split
the expense amongst each other now on
the next day when phil sends his share
to jack via online money transfer the
transaction goes through without a hitch
then ted and sam send their respective
shares to jack but their transactions
don't go through the failed transaction
cites some issues at the bank that's
when jack comes to know about the many
ways a bank transaction could fail it
could be due to technical issues at the
bank one of their accounts were hacked
daily transfer limits being exceeded and
sometimes additional charges like
transfer charges associated with
transferring money to solve these
problems the concept of cryptocurrency
came into existence cryptocurrencies are
a form of digital or virtual currency
that run on a technology known as
blockchain thanks to blockchain
cryptocurrencies are immune to
counterfeiting don't require a central
authority and are protected by strong
and complex encryption algorithms and in
a market of more than thousands of
cryptocurrencies like litecoin ethereum
c cash and so on one reign supreme
bitcoin now let's go back to our
previous example and have phil ted and
sam send jack two bitcoins each as their
contribution to the previous night's
dinner let's assume phil ted and sam
have three bitcoins in reserve while
jack has five first phil sends two
bitcoins to jack a record is created in
the form of a block the transaction
details between them is permanently
inscribed in this block this record also
holds the number of bitcoins each of the
friends own so after phil's transaction
jack has seven bitcoins while phil has
one following this sam and ted send two
bitcoins to jack a new block is created
for each of these transactions these
blocks hold the transaction details as
well as how many bitcoins sam ted and
jack have in reserve these blocks are
linked to each other as each of them
takes reference from the previous one
for the number of bitcoins each brand
owns this chain of records or blocks is
called a ledger and this ledger is
shared among all the friends which acts
as a public distributed ledger this
forms the basis of blockchain so what
happens when phil has only one bitcoin
left and he tries to send two more
bitcoins to jack the transaction will
not go through this is because all his
friends have copies of the ledger and
it's clear that phil has only one
bitcoin left his friends will flag this
transaction as invalid a hacker will not
be able to alter the data in the
blockchain because each user has a copy
of the ledger the data within the blocks
are encrypted by complex algorithms all
of this is made possible with the help
of blockchain technology blockchain can
be described as a collection of records
linked with each other strongly
resistant to alteration and protected
using cryptography now let's have a
closer look at the bitcoin transaction
between jack and phil and find out how
it works every user in the bitcoin
network has two keys a public key and a
private key the public key is an address
that everyone in the network knows of
like an email address of a user the
private key is a unique address that
only the user has knowledge of something
like a password first phil passes the
number of bitcoins he wants to send to
jack along with his and jack's unique
wallet address through a hashing
algorithm all of this is part of the
transaction details these details are
encrypted using encryption algorithms
and using phil's unique private key this
is done to digitally sign the
transaction and to indicate that the
transactions came from fill this output
is now transmitted across the world
using jack's public key with this the
message or transaction can be decrypted
only by jack's private key which only
jack has knowledge of different
cryptocurrencies use different hashing
algorithms while bitcoin uses the
sha-256 algorithm ethereum which is also
a famous cryptocurrency uses one known
as ethash
this transaction and several other
similar ones are taking place all around
the world these transactions are
validated and then added block by block
the people who validate these blocks are
called miners
for a block to be validated and added to
a blockchain miners need to solve a
complex mathematical problem the miner
who solves this first adds the block to
the blockchain and is rewarded with 12.5
bitcoins the process of solving the
complex mathematical problem is called
proof of work and the process of adding
a block to the blockchain is called
mining
with this phil and jack's wallets are
updated just like every person in the
network who has completed a transaction
now that you know about blockchain and
its important concepts time for a small
quiz what is the concept of blockchain
that ensures data cannot be altered by
any of the users within the network a
public distributed ledger b
proof of work
c
proof of stake d
hash encryption let us know what you
think is the right answer in the
comments below i'm hoping you guys
enjoyed this
now we have saurabh to tell us about
blockchain hello everyone and welcome to
this session of blockchain my name is
saurabh and i'm part of the simply learn
team so let's get started so what's in
it for you today we are here to
understand the concepts of why do we
need blockchain what is bitcoin and
blockchain how does blockchain work
concepts around blockchain like sha-256
encryption public and private key
distributed public ledger concept the
proof of work and mining then we will
also look at different applications of
blockchain in different industries who
uses blockchain and a demo now why we
need blockchain imagine there are two
entities a and b living far away and
want to transfer money to each other one
is in america and one is in asia as of
today in order to transfer the money
they rely on a third party on which they
have to trust now what are the possible
results by doing this way any
transaction there are high transaction
fees associated with it there could be
problem of double spending there could
be internet based frauds and poor data
recovery now let's see what does all
these means high transaction fee for any
transaction bank will charge a
relatively very high amount of
transaction free as compared to what as
of today cryptocurrency charges double
spending double spending is a digital
error where money can be spent twice
from your account so for example if you
have eight hundred dollars in your
account and you might end up spending
thousand dollars which is an invalid
transaction hackers might attack
financial institutions and gain
unauthorized access to steal your money
poor data recovery retrieving lost data
is very difficult in a centralized
system as there is only a single copy of
information but as compared to the
distributed databases the distributed
ledger technology like blockchain it is
easy as the information is distributed
across multiple nodes now these problems
can be solved using bitcoin and
blockchain technology and we will see
how so let's first understand what is
bitcoin and blockchain bitcoin bitcoin
is a digital currency which is used to
send and receive money across the world
it is a barrier-free currency in a
decentralized manner with minimum
transfer fee or we can say it's gonna be
relatively very very less as compared to
what bank charges it doesn't involve a
third party no intermediate reason
involved thereby reducing the cost of
transaction fast and cheap transfer is
possible personal information identity
of a user is hidden and all the
transactions are cryptographically
secure as they are being signed using
your private key bitcoin does this by
storing and transacting the money over a
distributed peer-to-peer network called
blockchain so therefore it becomes very
important for us in order to understand
if how bitcoin works we also need to
understand what is blockchain because
that is the underlying technology so
what is blockchain blockchain is a
distributed database of immutable
records called blocks which are secured
using cryptography now here we can see
once the data is recorded it cannot be
changed it cannot be altered and that is
the attribute of immutability of
blockchain a block is a record book
which contains the details of
transactional data every block is given
an aggregated set of transactions to be
validated verified and added to itself
so basically a block consists of four
primary details which we will take a
look at it contains the hash of a
previous block it contains an aggregated
list of transactions it also contains
the value of nonce and the hash for the
block itself which itself is like a
digital signature of the block so hash
of previous block it holds the hash
value of the previous block to which it
is connected contains details of several
transactions which are aggregated in
this block nonce nonce is a random
number a random value which is generated
to derive a hash value which should be
less than the target decided for the
block and hash is alphanumeric value
which is used to identify the block
itself and it is unique now let's deep
dive into blockchain blockchain creates
a chain of blocks as we can see here in
a blockchain the previous hash value of
a block is always equal to the hash
value of its previous block so as we can
see here the previous hash value of
block number two is 23a which is the
hash value of block one also the
previous hash value of block one is zero
because it is the first block in the
blockchain and it is called the genesis
block so the first block is called the
genesis block and does not have any
previous hash value so consider an
example now where a person tries to
tamper the block block number two then
he will try to change the hash of block
number 2 will change thereby the
previous hash value of block number 3
now does not stand valid now the hash
value of block 2 and block 3 does not
match which will make the following
blocks the blocks ahead of block number
two invalid now this particular feature
of blockchain helps us eliminate data
tampering now let's see how does
blockchain work jack wants to send money
to elsa the requested transaction of
jack wanting to send money to elsa will
be sent to all the peer nodes on the
network of computers now the transaction
sent to nodes is verify by a set of
people or a typical set of nodes called
miners once verified the transaction is
combined with other transactions to
create a new block in the blockchain and
as a result the receiving party elsa
receives the amount in blockchain a
transaction could be for a
cryptocurrency for data or any kind of
asset so the transaction can be for any
digital asset which holds value on the
network now let's take a look at what
are the typical features of blockchain
these are typical features of blockchain
it involves sha-256 algorithm-based
encryption proof-of-work consensus
algorithm usage of public and private
key in order to sign the messages on the
network the role of miners in order to
validate and verify the transactions and
how to create a now a distributed public
ledger now what is sha 256 encryption
for a transaction blockchain uses
cryptographic keys to secure identities
and hash function to make the blockchain
unalterable so cryptographic keys
includes two kind of keys private and
public key and it uses a hash function
which includes sha-256 now
sha-256 stands for the number of bit it
takes up in memory secure hashing
algorithm now hash function takes an
input data and always return an alpha
numeric output of 64 characters which is
256 bits so as you can see over here if
you feed any data like we are here
feeding an example of welcome to simply
learn the hashing function will return
you 256 bit value and now that hash
value is unique the value returned by a
hash function is called hash value it is
impossible to decode the original
message using the hash value itself so
hash value does not discloses the
original message in the hash function a
minor change in the input data will
result in a different hash value and
that is the unique feature of the
hashing function you make a small change
and the hashing value will change all
together completely now sha-256
is a one-way function you give an input
pass it through the hashing function you
get the output but the reverse is not
possible so in simple terms decrypting
back the original text is not possible
using sha-256 which makes it very very
secure now cryptography uses public and
private trees to encrypt and decrypt
data but a private key is always kept
secret with the user so if i have to
send a message to someone i will sign it
with my private key which is secret to
me but i'll share my public key in order
for users to decrypt the message and
validate that yes the sender of the
message is me so in the blockchain
network public key can be shared with
all the bitcoin users in order to do the
transaction so let's take a look what is
the entire verification process so when
you initiate a transaction it is passed
through a hashing function which in our
case is sha-256 the output is passed
through a signature algorithm with the
user's private key again and then we
receive a digitally signed document so
the hashing output plus my private key
is used to generate a digitally signed
document which is then floated on the
network with my public key then the
encrypted output is distributed to the
bitcoin network using the public key so
the digitally signed document and the
public key is used by the miners to
verify the transaction and once that is
done they include the transaction on the
block and the transaction is then marked
as completed so what is distributed
public ledger a blockchain is a
distributed ledger in which the digital
data is recorded and verified by each
node for preventing tempering of data so
if you can see over here we have a
network of nodes amongst these nodes few
might be the miners who are taking the
responsibility of verifying and
validating the transactions on each
block and in view of that verification
they will be rewarded so we will see
when we will be talking about mining so
let's take an example over here jack is
sending 10 btc to el elsa now which is
verified by john in the network john is
the miner now once the transaction is
verified by john the result is being
broadcasted is transferred to other
nodes as a result the block becomes
valid and gets added to the blockchain
and once it is transferred to other
nodes the ledger of each node records
this transaction
and all the ledgers now have the same
information on the network to note only
a valid transaction is propagated across
the bitcoin users while if any invalid
transaction is identified it is
discarded at the first node itself which
received it now what if any user tries
to tamper the data every user in the
blockchain maintains a copy of the
ledger so as i said once the
transactions are verified they are
distributed across the nodes all the
ledgers are updated now if someone goes
back in the blockchain and tries to
tamper the data in one of the blocks the
other nodes will be able to identify the
invalid block and will discard it so if
anyone tries to modify the data the
alternate transaction copies with other
users will negate the alteration now
let's take a look at the proof of work
algorithm proof of work is a consensus
algorithm which is used in the bitcoin
network it is the process to determine a
number called as nonce along with the
cryptographic hashing algorithm to
produce a hash value lower than the
predefined target for the block so if
you see over here the miners main task
is to identify the nonce which is the
random number in order to generate the
hash value which is less than the target
now generally the target is something
like the hash value should have leading
zeroes like here in the example we can
see it is having leading zeros of two
leading zeros so in order to generate a
hash value with leading zeros like two
or three it takes huge amount of
computing power for the miners to
determine that so in order to determine
the nouns the miners need to try about
20.6 quadrillion nouns values to get a
one valid hash now how it works
transaction data is distributed across
the users of bitcoin network miners will
validate the unverified transactions add
them to the block that is their task to
do so miners compete to solve a
difficult mathematical puzzle which is
the generation of the nonce value based
on cryptographic hashing function and
this whole process is known as proof of
work the first miner who solves the
puzzle gets rewarded and this is the
purpose for which the miner has made the
investment in the hardware in the
computing power the energy which the
mining machine is consuming in order to
get the reward once the miner has
verified the block it is added to the
blockchain now let's take a look at the
process using the sha-256
you generate a hash value use nonce as
an input to the hashing function if the
hash value is less than the target no
then you modify the nonce value you
repeat this activity if it is less than
the target value yes then you are deemed
to get the reward your puzzle is solved
note in the bitcoin network the target
is adjusted every two 2016 blocks so as
i mentioned the target of having leading
three zeros or having leading four zeros
that is revised after every two zero one
six blocks on an average a block is
mined every 10 minutes the difficulty of
the puzzle is maintained in such a way
that it never deviates too much from the
average time taken to minor block now
candidate block proof of work so let's
consider an example where a miner jack
is competing to validate the block
number thousand now while jack was
mining block number thousand he was also
listening for new transactions so in the
transaction pool the transaction are
stored they are basically parked until
they get verified and gets included in a
new block now unfortunately before jack
could bind thousands someone else mined
it and earned the reward now block
thousand has a valid proof of work now
it is a verified block so now jack will
start constructing a candidate block
which will be on the subsequent block
sequential 1001 by gathering the
unverified transaction now from the
transaction pool so jack has now started
creating a candidate block pulling the
transactions from the transaction pool
into block number 1001 the current block
now is the candidate block because it
has not been validated and does not have
any proof of work yet this block 1001
gets validated once any miner succeeds
in solving the proof of work it could be
jack or it could be again someone else
competing mining in blockchain when the
transaction contained are considered
confirmed a new block is added to the
existing blockchain and the bitcoins
concerned in the transaction now can be
spent now as of today the miner who
solves a puzzle gets a reward of 12.5
bitcoins the amount of bitcoin rewarded
for each block added to the blockchain
is half for every 2 lakh 10 000 blocks
which is approximately every four year
so this is called the huffing concept of
bitcoin so approximately whenever the
four-year threshold will be reached the
reward will get reduced to 6.25 bitcoins
now let's take a look of applications of
blockchain in different industries
voting blockchain is a is a very
trustworthy mechanism which has
increased transparency in the voting
process supply chain uses the attributes
of blockchain of provenance and
traceability to detect to identify and
trace the supply of any asset from its
point of origin to its final destination
and if in due course any defect is
detected it can easily identify where in
the journey of the asset the defect was
generated insurance has a huge adoption
they are utilizing blockchain for
eliminating forgery and preventing false
claims as all the records and
transactions will be maintained in
blockchain immutable ledger it will be
very difficult for anyone to apply for
any false claim so as an example if the
health records are there on blockchain
the insurance companies can easily
validate the health claims made by any
patient through the blockchain digital
reports accounting it virtually
maintains a record of accurate financial
information all the financial
transactions if maintained on an
immutable ledger can easily be validated
and verified and makes accounting simple
now who uses blockchain there are
organizations across the globe who are
adopting and have started using
blockchain example walmart due to
blockchain's decentralized system the
company is able to protect its data from
hacking and detoleration british airways
with blockchain flight data from various
sources are merged together and help
passengers receive accurate information
maersk with blockchain the company is
able to provide an efficient transparent
and secure service in global trade
brilliant earth in order to track and
trace the provenance of high value
gemstones they are using blockchain now
let's take a look at a demo let's go
over to some concepts which we have just
learned now here i want to demonstrate a
usage of the hashing function so as we
had learned the hashing function is a
256 big hashing function sha-256 you can
type in any data and it will always
generate a 256 bit hash and it's gonna
be unique it's a one way function so it
is not possible that you will be able to
derive the data from the hash value and
if i type the same data it will generate
the same hash value so the hash value
for blank is the same and if i type
anything it will always generate the
same hash value for the same data set
now let's see how can we use the hashing
function in our block now here we have a
block which has its attributes which is
the block number a nonce value and like
the similar hashing function we have the
data set and a hash value now the
difficulty level the target is already
set for the hashing function to have
four leading zeros so whenever i'll be
mining the job of the miner here is to
generate a hash which should have four
leading zeroes in the hash value and it
will use it will guess the nonce value
in order to generate such a hash which
is having four leading zeros so suppose
if i type a data set now the hash which
is right now you're seeing on the screen
is not mined and it does not have the
leading zeros the four leading zeros so
when i'll click mine the nonce value
will change the miner has to guess the
nonce value to get the hash which is
having four leading zeros
here it is so the non switch is
generated now which is 57 480. it takes
huge amount of time processing power so
it could have gone a pretty high value
but it was able to guess it at a decent
amount of time now as soon as i'll
change the value again the block has
turned pink which means it is not
verified the hash has to be generated
now we will see the same concept we will
have multiple blocks in our blockchain
now here we have multiple blocks but we
have a new extra attribute called
previous hash so if you notice the
blocks right now currently have all the
previous values of the hash which are of
their previous blocks block number 2 has
the previous hash value of 4015 which is
the hash value of its previous block and
this is how a typical blockchain is
constructed now there are few things to
be noted here suppose i modify the data
in the last block so if you see the
block hash now needs to be changed
because the data has changed its hash
has to be regenerated so the previous
hash value is the same which was the
hash value of the previous block now the
new hash has been generated for this
block which starts with four leading
zeros another thing to be noted is
suppose i go back in the sequence and
modify the data of any of the previous
blocks so all the blocks ahead of this
block number three now have to be
verified again because the signature of
block number three has changed therefore
the values of the previous hash have to
be updated for block number four and
five so when i'll mine block number
three it has now generated a hash value
which is as per the target block number
four also has to be mined and blocked
number five also has to be mined now
this way we have created our valid
blockchain so this demonstrates if
someone in a regular blockchain a
mainnet blockchain which has high number
of blockchains blocks so if they go and
tamper any block in the past all the
subsequent blocks ahead of that block
have to be mined again which will take
huge huge amount of time and processing
power which makes it impossible now we
will see this concept when we'll take
this concept of distributed now here we
have a distributed ledger we have three
peers pra peer b prc all have the same
copy of the ledgers
now suppose there is someone who has
modified the data on pra and generated a
block updated the block but the hash
value of
block in peer a or for block number five
is different for what is of block number
five at prp prb which is the four time
zero e4 and pse also has the same hash
signature for as peer b so easily the
participants in the distributed network
will able to be identify that someone
has modified block number five at pra
which is not a valid block and it can
get disregarded now whatever example i
have been showing this has all been
random data we can take a look at the
typical transaction which actually
happens on a bitcoin network now rather
than sending random data we can see here
the exact examples of the transactions
the transfer of money which actually
happens from one account to another so
this is a very good way to see that
these are the ways typically the
transactions are aggregated and mined in
a block and we can see in a typical
fashion all the three peers have the
same set of information on the
distributed ledger now if i modify any
of the transaction the block will get
invalidated and it would have to be
remind blockchain tutorial part one so
let's get started and understand what's
in it for us today so let's check in
hypothesis in a city not so far away
somebody was up to something bad so
there's a hacker who hates the bank who
wants to steal the money of all the
people lying in the bank
now here's why i hate them even more
what are the nuances and the problem
areas of the banking system the banking
system has higher transactional and
international transfer costs a lot of
documentation is required for setting up
an account for opening an account and
onboarding a customer and the banking
system is not always accessible it's not
24x7 it's closed on banking holidays and
it has other limitations also like
transfer limits in a day and you know
you can't transfer x amount within a
stipulated time now banks in such an
ecosystem acts as a center point of
failure it is a centralized based system
which is prone to failure from a
centralized point of view so if the bank
fails all the transactions will come to
an halt which are dependent on the bank
now let's see what happens if the hacker
is able to get into the banking system
and hacks the bank all the investors or
the people associated with the bank the
information associated with them will
get corrupted will get jeopardized and
it can lead to huge losses to the bank
and to the individuals and all this can
happen with a click of a button it's as
simple as that so once a hacker has
access to the system he can manipulate
the system compromise the information
share it with the parties which are not
supposed to have that information and
lot can go wrong though the hackers can
be caught right it is possible through
cyber security and various means but
once the information is compromised it
is very difficult to roll that back and
that's why we need more secure systems
and systems which are not dependent on a
centralized authority which work in a
more decentralized fashion thereby
making it hack proof plus lowering the
transaction cost also now this incident
of course will catch the bank manager's
attention now he will go to his advisors
and want to make sure this does not
happen again so the technology com
people the advisors will make sure that
this does not happen but what is the
remedy so the remedy is setting up a
blockchain now of course the manager
who's looking into the banking functions
might not be aware of the technology and
what benefits blockchain bring onto the
table in order to prevent such an
incident so that's what we are here for
we will learn before we go and
understand what can blockchain actually
achieve for us so we will understand
today what is blockchain the bitcoin
story the features of blockchain like
public distributed ledger the hashing
encryption the proof of work consensus
algorithm and the concept of mining and
then we will cover up a use case where
how blockchain can be used for banking
operations now what is blockchain
blockchain is a list of records called
blocks which stores data publicly and in
a chronological order and the entire
information is persisted using
cryptography it is secured using
cryptography so cryptography ensures
that the privacy of the user is
maintained and data cannot be altered
information on a blockchain network is
not controlled by a centralized
authority so unlike modern financial
institutions nobody controls the data
within a blockchain the data is
maintained by the participants of the
network and they are the democratic
authority in order to approve any
transaction which can happen on a
blockchain network access to anyone on
the network so a typical blockchain
network is a public blockchain so as
long as you have access to the network
you have access to the data within the
blockchain if you are a participant on
the blockchain network you will have the
same copy of the ledger which all other
participants have so therefore everyone
every participant on the network has the
same copy of the data so everyone in the
network has a copy of the blockchain
data which is used for ensuring the data
remains untempered so even if one node
or data on one particular participant
computer gets corrupted the other
participants will come to know
immediately that this particular
instance or node has gone corrupted and
they will rectify it as soon as possible
so basically the question is is this the
same technology that bitcoin works on
and the answer is yes bitcoin could not
have been possible without blockchain so
we will understand how bitcoin adopted
blockchain in order to reach to its
journey today so bitcoin was introduced
in 2009 by someone or a group of people
known as satoshi nakamoto it aimed to
solve the problem faced by fiat
currencies with the help of blockchain
technology now as of today in 2018 there
are more than 1600 cryptocurrencies that
follow the concepts of bitcoin and
blockchain for example the other popular
cryptocurrencies are like ethereum
litecoin dash ripple and many more now
let me explain how a bitcoin transaction
works the sender transmits the
transaction details worldwide basically
whenever a sender has to do a
transaction he has to send bitcoins to a
receiver he will submit the transaction
on the public blockchain network of
bitcoin and transmit it now verification
to authenticate users it is done by the
miners around the world so basically
there are specific participants in the
bitcoin network which are called as
miners whose job is to verify the
authenticity of the sender and the
receiver and also validate whether the
sender has the right amount of balance
for the bitcoin which he is trying to
send to the receiver and ensuring that
the sanity of the underlying blockchain
network to the bitcoin remains correct
and not get corrupted so once the miner
has authenticated the transaction
verified all the parameters the
transaction is added to a block and then
that block is made part of the main
blockchain once the block is added to
the blockchain the money the
transactions which were associated in
the block then gets executed money is
deducted from the sender's wallet and is
added to the receiver wallet thereby
once the transaction is completed the
block is added and the ledger across all
the nodes are updated each and every
participant ledger copy is updated with
that particular block which has been
added in the blockchain so therefore all
the participants have the same copy of
the information now so what makes
blockchain special now these are the
special four features of blockchain
which we're going to talk about in
detail it is a public distributed ledger
it works using a hashing encryption each
and every block has a hash value which
is the digital signature of the block
all the transactions are approved and
verified on the blockchain network using
proof of work consensus algorithm and
the blockchain network utilizes the
resources of the miners who are there to
validate the transaction and the miners
in lieu of putting up investing in the
resources and validating the
transactions get rewards in terms of
bitcoin and that process is called
mining now public distributed ledger
let's imagine four friends sharing a
particular document amongst each other
correct now if there was only a single
copy of that document and one of them
alter the data it may go unnoticed
however the outcome would be different
if each one of them had a copy of the
data so therefore if each and every
participant has the same copy of the
data even if one of them changed the
data the others would find that the data
does not match with their own so
blockchain works in a similar fashion
the data within a blockchain is
accessible to everyone so with this as
long as you are part of the network you
could access the entire history of
transactions that have taken place since
the blockchain was created since
inception and the first block in any
blockchain is called the genesis block
so from the genesis block to the current
block you will have the access to the
entire chain any additions to blocking
have to be approved by the participant
users in the blockchain network so a
majority of the members within the
network have to approve of any additions
to the blockchain this is the public
part of the ledger and this is important
because any additions made to the
blockchain are permanent and are
immutable so immutable transactions are
the transactions which cannot be altered
once registered they cannot be modified
and are available for audit and
verification 24x7 so this means that
each and every detail is recorded and
any alterations can be detected by
verifying it against everyone's personal
version of the blockchain so if
someone's tried to modify a data on a
block on a particular node then the
other ledgers which are having the same
information will come to know that
someone has modified data on a one
particular node and they will try to
rectify and the fourth property no
central authority is controlling the
working of this blockchain network it is
a decentralized network so this is where
being decentralized helps everyone has a
copy of the blockchain which means there
is no central point of failure there is
a single source of truth even if things
go wrong the data can be recovered if
one node goes wrong the data can be
recovered from other nodes but what
about security how is privacy maintained
if everything is so public and here
hashing encryptions comes into picture
it takes care of that now we will talk
about the second feature which is
hashing encryption but to understand
hashing encryption we need to understand
the contents what are the contents of a
block so a block in a blockchain is like
a container that holds aggregated
transactions it contains certain set of
transactions so we will see what all
things construct a particular block so a
block has two parts it has a header and
it has the second part is the
transaction details it is the set of
transactions which are aggregated in
this block now the header has following
set of attributes it has the block
version number it has the hash of the
previous block to which it is linked the
current timestamp the timestamp at which
the block was verified the nonce nonce
we will see what is the attribute what
is the meaning of nonce and target value
now the transaction details are nothing
but the example which we talked about
earlier it is the transaction which the
sender and receiver are sharing the
sender is trying to send certain amount
of bitcoin from his account to the
receiver's account now it is represented
in the form of a 256 bit hash value in
the header called as merkle root or the
hash root so basically the merkle root
is the hash of all the transactions
structured in a merkle tree called
binary tree it's a kind of a binary tree
and the hash value of the root node of
the merkle tree is called the merkle
root hash so the transaction details of
a block are contained in the header in a
hex value known as merkle root the
merkle root can be calculated in this
way so basically the list of transaction
each transaction is passed through a
hashing algorithm then all the hashes of
the transactions are paired and then
again passed through another hashing
algorithm until only one value remains
and which will be the root now let me
tell you how a hash function works
blockchain utilizes a hash function to
perform cryptography data from a data
set of random size is sent as input to a
hashing function to get an encrypted
value of fixed size and that is the
feature of any hashing function so some
unique properties of hashing function
are these are deterministic the same
input will always produce the same hash
output small changes in the data can
drastically change the output so
basically
any small change to the input produces
an output that's drastically different
from its previous obtained outputs it
can be computed easily the output values
can be obtained without a whole lot of
calculation and hashing functions are
one-way functions basically you won't be
able to determine the input based on the
output value so you can't do the reverse
calculation now let's go back to our
block we were talking about earlier so
as we were discussing what are the
features in the header the previous hash
is the resultant hash of the previous
block in the blockchain and this is the
way two blocks are linked together now
transaction details these are used to
provide details about the sender
receiver and how much money they want to
exchange between them and this is a list
of transactions and they are structured
in a merkle tree and the hash of the
merkle root is put in the header nonce
is a value that is varied to create a
unique hash address of the block which
should be less than the target hash
value so this is the structure of the
header it has a block version number
basically the sequence number of the
block it has the hash of the previous
block the timestamp when the block was
mined and verified the nonce value the
header is then this entire header is
then passed through a hashing algorithm
in the case of a bitcoin network it is
sha-256 and a hash value is generated
and now this hash value becomes the hash
value of the block now this value is a
256 bit value that is used to uniquely
identify the particular block so she 256
ensures that alterations to data can be
easily detected so for example consider
these two blocks in the blockchain they
have a similar structure and definitely
different hash values now if someone
alters the transaction details in the
first block the corresponding hash value
of the block would change too now the
values of hash value of the first block
and the previous hash value of the other
block will not match basically the block
subsequent to the hacked block will get
dealing now this will raise an alarm
among the users informing them that data
alteration has taken place the users
will then be able to flag the block so
the alteration can be easily identified
and rectified immediately to ensure
security blockchains also include
digital signatures these ensure that the
message come from the right identity
right person and that the message is not
tampered with users are provided their
own private and public key so whenever a
user onboard a public blockchain he is
provided a pair of public and private
key now private key is used by the user
to control his her own account this is
kept as a secret by the user so
basically it is like his own password
and public key public key is used to
identify the user on the network this is
shared by the user along with the
transaction on the network for others to
verify so these are the steps involved
in creating and authenticating a digital
signature so at the center side the
message to be transmitted is passed
through the hashing algorithm in in this
case of bitcoin it is she-256 and the
hash is generated plus the private key
is used to generate a digital signature
now this output is passed through a
signature algorithm along with the
user's private key to create a digital
signature now during the transmission
the user's message their digital
fingerprint which was generated in the
previous step plus the public key are
transmitted across the network so these
three things are published on the
network for the validators for the
miners to use and verify the
authenticity of the sender now at the
receiver's end first the message is
passed through a hashing algorithm now
at the same time the sender's public key
and his or her digital signature are
passed through a very fictional
algorithm now both the functions will
generate a hash if both the hashes are
compared and if they match then the
transaction and the identity of the
sender is approved otherwise it is
rejected so basically this is the
process by comparing the hash values to
authenticate the identity of the sender
now what about the people who verify
these transactions and how do they
actually do it so remember that one
field in the block header called norms
that becomes very important in order to
verify the transaction so now we will
talk about the third feature which is
the proof of work consensus algorithm so
proof of work involves people around the
world the participants in the network
called miners competing to be the first
one to add a block to the blockchain and
in lieu of this they will be rewarded
there are competing miners around the
world they are trying to solve a
mathematical puzzle to be the first one
to be rewarded and to add a block to the
blockchain so this is the reward so
thereby they invest in the computing
power they invest in the resources in
order to mine and validate a transaction
to get that reward now what is the
mathematical puzzle so basically they
need to find a hash value that satisfies
certain predefined conditions now in
order to find the hash value they will
use norms so this target hash value is
decided months in advance for every
block the miners keep variating the
nonce value to find out an output that
falls within the target requirement so
they keep on generating a hash value
using the norms and if it is less than
the target the hash value is accepted
and if it is greater than the hash value
is rejected the minus effort is not
considered valid now a minor transmits
across the world that he has found a
nonce that satisfies the target
requirement as soon as he find it and
thanks to the hashing algorithm used
this claim can be easily verified by
others so basically the proof of work
algorithm it is very hard to generate
the nonce and get the hash value but it
is very easy to verify the transaction
by the other miners so that's a whole
lot of work what a miner's payoff is so
for all his or her hard work they get
paid in the bitcoins and this is the
only way the bitcoins get added to the
network sometimes they get other forms
of remuneration as well and this is the
concept of mining so the entire process
when the miner has done the proof of
work consensus they are rewarded and
this is called as mining so mining is
the process of adding a block to the
blockchain this miner is the first
person who found a nonce value that fell
within the target requirement right now
for doing this the miner is rewarded as
of today on the bitcoin network a miner
is paid 12.5 bitcoins for adding a block
onto the blockchain but the reward a
miner gets reduced by half every four
years so when the fourth year will
approach for the threshold the bitcoin
reward will go down to 6.25 bitcoins and
miners also get the sum of all the
transaction fees for that particular
block so the 12.5 bitcoin reward is
justified as mining is a very expensive
process it has a heavy toll on
electricity computing power and other
resources on which the miner has
invested now we will take a look at the
use cases where blockchain is applicable
in banks so we have been incorporating a
program where banks can validate user
identity as of now a user needs to do
the process over and over again in each
bank he has to go and prove the identity
in each bank is there a way we can ease
the process with blockchain and the
answer is yes we can we will be using
truffle ethereum ganache and smart
contracts all of these blockchain
technology ecosystem to make it work and
welcome to this demo for how to build
your kyc blockchain application now i'm
gonna show you all the steps required to
deploy your kyc application what all
components are to be developed and how
to go about deploying and testing your
application so primarily this kyc
application will allow banks to do us
decentralized kyc of the customers which
come to their banks so in the demo we
will see when a customer walks into the
initiating bank will do the kyc for a
customer enter its details and verify it
and if any subsequent bank wants to use
the kyc done by another bank he or she
needs to take the permission of the
customer and then he can use the same
kyc for verification so we will see how
can we do that so just to start off with
we have developed a kyc
solidity contract
which has all the necessary functions in
order to do the actions required
for doing a kyc of a particular entity
by the bank now once this contract is
ready we will be placing it in our
sample truffle package so this is my
truffle package and in this i have the
contracts folder in the contracts folder
i have kept my kyc dot solve file
now in the command prompt i will
compile my contracts
we can ignore the warnings
so here is my ganache client which i
have just started and in my ganache
client as you can see it is running on
port 8545 and it has already given me 10
accounts pre-funded with 100 ether now i
had already mentioned that my truffle is
connected to localhost 8545. so now when
i'll do my truffle migrate command it
will connect to my ganache
and deploy my kyc contract so now i can
go to full control and for me it's very
important to see at which particular
address my solidity contract has been
deployed i'll copy it
and in my
ui code under root jscontractdetails.js
i will make the change of this address
where my contract has now been deployed
now after doing these steps my
application is ready to interact with my
solidity contract which is being
deployed on my local blockchain network
now as you can see when i deployed the
contract this is my primary account from
which the ethers were deducted in order
to deploy the contract now there are
certain steps in order to get the
application up and running so first we
need to sign up the banks
so suppose i say bank one and the
password should be the first address of
the bank so basically we are associating
one bank with one account which we have
on our ethereum network so we will sign
up now bank one is successfully
registered so i now in order to login i
can check
now bank one i have logged in now i need
to do add a kyc for a particular
customer
now after filling the basic details i
will create the customer and the
username i have kept is customer1
ideally this is the unique identity of
the customer it can be any social
security number or the number or any
unique identity which is attached to the
customer or the email id and can be used
as the unique identifier for the
customer now once customer profile is
successfully created we need to login as
a customer to allow this bank to see the
kyc details now suppose if i say
customer one and search it it is saying
access denied and take the permission
from customer to proceed so
before the bank can do the kyc complete
the customer need to approve it so i am
creating the credentials for the
customer
now customer can see his details
whatever were filled by bank one and he
can see that there is a request from
bank one to allow to view his kyc now
before we allow i will also create
another bank bank 2 and associate it
with my another address
and try to log in with it
now bank 2 is also logged in now bank 2
has not done the original kyc right but
it is trying to look up and its access
is also denied so it needs to explicitly
take permission so the bank will take
explicit requests from the customer
so now the customer has requests from
bank one and bank two for the kyc it is
up to the customer whether he or she
wants to allow and deny the kyc request
after the permission has been granted
then only the banks can be able to view
the kyc so if i say bank one allow and
bank to deny
now all the requests are done from the
queue so bank one was allowed and bank
two was denied so if i again log in with
bank one
and the password is my first address
view kyc customer one
so here it is the bank one is able to
see the details now if i log in as
bank two and give password and try to
see the it is saying permission denied
so let's ask bank 2 to again request
now bank 2 is now again requesting and
now this time it allows
now bank 2 can see the details so all
these transactions in the back end are
happening on the blockchain network
which is interfacing with the contract
through its subsequent methods now the
primary details of the contract are in
the
contractdetails.javascript where we have
to provide the address at which the
contract was deployed the abi file the
api so you can get the api at here this
is the avi and you can paste it here and
this is the binary data
which has to be
pasted over here so the binary data can
be fetched
from remix
this is the binary data for the contract
it has to be copied and pasted over here
now with these essential inputs provided
our application allows us to interact in
a decentralized fashion to access the
kyc records of a particular customer now
we can modify
the details also
and we can add a new customer again so
this is a basic demo of how a typical
kyc application works in a banking
environment blockchain tutorial part two
so let's get started today and let's see
what's in store for us so hey thanks for
coming back to explain how blockchain
work so in our last session just let's
do a quick recap what we have learned so
let's look down the memory lane and
discover what we had learned we learned
about what blockchain is so a blockchain
is a list of records which stores data
publicly in a chronological order it
applies security using cryptography it
is not controlled by a centralized
authority any information on a
blockchain network is accessible to
anyone on the network and as it is a
distributed ledger it's a shared ledger
everyone has the copy of the data so
these are the primary attributes of a
blockchain also you learned about
bitcoin and how it works just to do a
quick recap it was introduced in 2009 by
someone or a group of pseudonymous
people known as satoshi nakamoto it
aimed to solve the problems faced by
fiat currencies with the help of
blockchain technology so the objective
was to introduce a new asset class of
cryptocurrencies which can be used in
day-to-day transactions now as of in
2018 there are more than 1600
cryptocurrencies that follow the concept
of bitcoin and blockchain and are very
popular in our day-to-day lives now
let's talk about the features of
blockchain is a public distributed
ledger it uses a hashing encryption to
encrypt all the information on the
blockchain it uses proof of work
consensus algorithm for a consensus
mechanism and it works with the concept
of mining in order to reward the miners
for keeping them and maintaining the
sanity of the network and finally about
how you can implement blockchain in a
banking system so we talked about how to
implement a kyc based blockchain
decentralized app and how it allows you
to create a decentralized banking system
where a kyc done by a one bank can be
leveraged by another bank and the
customer does not have to go through
multiple kyc iterations with each and
every bank whom he or she wants to
transact with now we will get a little
deeper into blockchain and today we will
talk about these topics we will talk
about what is a candidate block we will
talk about byzantine fault tolerance
which was one of the earlier consensus
mechanisms then we will talk about the
problem of if we have to add two blocks
at the same time then how does
blockchain handles that then we will
talk about the concept of forking what
are soft folks what are hard folks and
other areas where blockchain is getting
used what is the future of blockchain
and what are the upcoming blockchain
jobs and the profiles which are upcoming
in the market and then in the end we
will do a quick demo on how to create a
smart contract and deploy it for a
particular use case now before a block
can be mined a miner has to make a very
important decision which transactions
would be added to his block so before
transactions are added to the blockchain
they are collected in a temporary
container called a memory pool the
miners select transactions from the
school and they put it in a temporary
block called candidate block so
basically the candidate block is a
temporary block which a miner hopes to
add to a blockchain it's a candidate to
be added to a blockchain so the
candidate block holds transactions that
the miner selects from the memory pool
the miner then tries to be the first
person to find the nonce value that
satisfy the hash requirements now the
question comes if someone in a
blockchain wanted to input the wrong
data by spreading wrong information
around would he or she be able to get
away with it and that's why we had
something known as byzantine fault
tolerance so in order to maintain the
sanity of the network and to have the
correct consensus there was something
called as byzantine fault tolerance
consensus algorithm to understand this
you need to know what the byzantine
general's problem is so let's imagine a
byzantine general and three other
lieutenants need to take over this town
however they are at different places and
can't directly communicate with each
other so here we have the general and
his three lieutenants the general has to
ensure that all lieutenants follow the
same order he or she gives them to
attack or to retreat now this has to be
ensured even if one of the lieutenants
is a traitor so this is the byzantine
general's problem that how does the
general communicates the correct
decision which he has taken to all his
lieutenants in his network irrespective
if someone is a traitor in this case a
traitor could ruin the unity of the
group by sending different messages to
different lieutenants now here we can
see that general is giving all his
definitions the command to attack the
traitor could ruin this by sending every
other left hand the command to retreat
the opposite now in this suspicion the
traitor would make others believe that
the general asks them to retreat so as
we can see the lieutenant in brown is
the traitor and he could communicate to
other lieutenants the wrong information
and make them act on his behalf as a
traitor in themselves now this would
cause the lieutenants to retreat and the
general's attack to fail so how do we
tackle this the only way an attack or a
retreat will be successful is by having
a majority supporting that particular
action to achieve this the lieutenants
keep a tally of the orders they receive
so in this scenario the general sends
the attack order to each of his
lieutenants the lieutenants in turn
collect the order they receive and pass
it on to the left in end near to them so
each left-hand will pass this order to
the nearest left in it the traitor also
will do the same but sends the retreat
order to the other left lanes however
this will not be successful because each
lieutenant now has a majority of attack
and minority of retreat so this shows
that the majority of the lieutenants
would follow the general's command and
the attack will be successful the
scenario i mentioned before is byzantine
fault tolerance now the same situation
can be encountered in blockchain as well
the traitor would add invalid
transactions into the blockchain the
trader would send the inconsistent
information to other nodes in a
blockchain this would affect the
reliability of blockchain network
blockchain are able to achieve byzantine
fault tolerance with the help of proof
of work let's see how it is effective it
is effective because the process of
adding a block to a blockchain is a work
intensive process which involves a
hashing algorithm the process is very
hard very computative because it is
heavily reliant on value obtained from
the existing blockchain to have any
meaningful impact the hacker would have
to take a lot of time
resources producing sufficient proof of
work interesting imagine if you and i
were miners and we both add a block to
the blockchain at the same time how do
we handle the situation so although this
does not happen very often there is a
way to decide whose block should be
added to the blockchain in an ideal
scenario you just need to be the first
one to find the hash value you need to
be the first miner to generate that hash
value and win the block so adding two
blocks at the same time the hash value
of the block only needs to be within the
predetermined limit if the generated
hash value is less than the target then
the value is accepted and the block is
added to the blockchain but if it is
greater than the target then the value
is denied and the block is not added to
the blockchain but in this case if two
people have obtained a satisfactory hash
value at the same time so minor one and
minor two were able to find the hash
which was less than the target then what
will happen whether minus one block will
get added to the blockchain or minus two
block will get added to the blockchain
now fifty percent of the network has
accepted minus one block and suppose
rest has accepted minus two blocks so
half of the network continues to work
considering minus one block to be the
right block and the other half network
continues to work considering minus two
block to be the right block however only
one minus blockchain can be allowed to
remain we cannot have two blockchains
running it will defeat the purpose now
this is achieved by selecting the sub
chain to which miners have first added a
block so suppose miner 3 adds a new
block to miners 1 blockchain this block
now added by miner 3 is verified by
everyone in the network it is then
accepted as the dominant blockchain and
is used by everyone else in the network
the other version of the blockchain the
miner 2 is completely discarded and the
entire network now accepts miner one's
blockchain and we have now a single
blockchain existing now this efficient
is also called an accidental fork so i
heard about a version of bitcoin called
bitcoin cash what's the difference
between them there are other kinds too
like bitcoin gold and bitcoin private
these are all outcomes of a fork so what
is a fork a fork is said to have taken
place when a blockchain diverges into
two potential parts a fork happens when
the users of a network cannot come to an
agreement with regards to a network's
transaction details and the new rules to
validate those transactions so there are
two types of forks which can exist
either it can be a soft work or it can
be a hard fork a soft fork occurs when a
change in the soft protocol makes new
blocks added to the blockchain following
the new rules but are backward
compatible but in order to have a
software it requires a majority of the
users to commit to that change to be
successful so a soft fork could have
multiple uses it could be for tighter
rules it could be for cosmetic changes
addition of new functions but not
affecting the structure so consider the
scenario where the accepted block size
is to be reduced from 1 mb to 100 kb so
first of all it has to be approved by a
majority of the network now the old
version will be running on 1 mb block
size but once approved the new version
will start working on a block size of
100 kb so anything which is less than
100 kb will be approved and will be
added to the new block so over time
people following the older version of
the blockchain would be forced to move
to the new one since none of the
transactions would go through so
basically people using the old
blockchain they will be using the 1mb
block size their transactions will not
succeed and they will be forced to use
the 100kb block now let's talk about
hard fork a hard fork involves a change
in the software protocol so radical that
it forces a new blockchain to be created
altogether so basically in a hard fork
there will be two versions there will be
one blockchain that hasn't upgraded and
there will be a blockchain that has
upgraded according to the new software
protocols both these blockchains will be
considered valid and legitimate the new
path would follow new updated rules
while the other one keeps following the
old path so the old one will not be
discarded and will remain into existence
now bitcoin performed a hard fork on
first august 2017 which created bitcoin
cash so thereby both bitcoin and bitcoin
cash remain existent now bitcoin cash
was different from regular bitcoin
because it increased the block size from
1 mb to 8 mb so thereby it helped
reducing the transaction cost
significantly lesser than that of the
original bitcoin network now other than
with bitcoin where else is blockchain
used the other areas are for preventing
voter fraud blockchain helps in ensuring
that there is only one vote per person
ensuring that the data is not being
tampered with or any false alterations
are done it helps creating an immutable
ledger to record the votes as tallied so
once a transaction or a vote is recorded
it cannot be modified it is also used in
quality assurance ensuring the products
are of highest quality being able to
identify problem areas easily so where
do you think blockchain is going to be
used in the future so blockchain is
seeing wide range of adoption amongst
organizations as of now only one percent
of all organizations have begun using
blockchain technologies but this
percentage is expected to increase in
the next five years or so then there is
a need for blockchain regulations the
rules and regulations surrounding
blockchain are not very clear for
organizations to be comfortable using it
and move towards faster adoption also
there's a need for removing this
negative speculations surrounding
blockchain several industries fear that
blockchain will disrupt their normal
functioning and believe that the
adoption of a blockchain system isn't
worth the effort and there is an
increase in job opportunities for
skilled personnel so as the technology
is maturing there would be a huge
requirement for individuals who can
understand and implement the concepts of
blockchain so what options do people
have for jobs involving blockchain at
the moment there are many job
opportunities but the two most famous
ones are blockchain architect and
blockchain developer blockchain
developer is a profile which requires
designing implementing and supporting a
distributed blockchain network analyze
user requirements design technology
around a certain business model to build
and launch a blockchain network
blockchain architect profile requires to
design and architect blockchain industry
solutions creates blockchain networks
leveraging blockchain technology
platforms produce high quality code
based on project requirements
conceptualize design and build
blockchain frameworks and assets
so let's have a quick demo on how to
deploy a rating smart contract and have
decentralized application running on a
local blockchain network we will be
using truffle and solidity to build this
application so in order to build this
application we should have installed
truffle and ganache on our local system
so this is a ganache client which is
running on my local host it is running
on port
8545 and network id 5778 whenever you
run a ganache client it is preceded with
10 accounts and 100 ether balance now
this is my movie rating app and in this
app i am going to deploy a smart
contract called rating.soul which is
gonna capture the ratings for a certain
set of movies which i will predefine and
the users will be able to set the
ratings on a blockchain network in a
decentralized fashion and we will be
able to see that in every transaction a
block is getting generated in my ganache
client so in my movie rating app under
the rating folder i will run the command
trough compile and it will compile my
smart contract rating dot soul now the
next command which i have to run is
trough migrate
now at this instance the trough migrate
command will deploy
my smart contract on my ganache client
so if you see there are four blocks
which have been created and
my contract was created in this
transaction and this is the address of
the contract at which my contract is
deployed so i can go back to my command
prompt and say trust console and check
the address of my
contract so this is 0x695
which is this address now when i
deployed my smart contract i had given
the entry of deployment in a file called
deploy contract.js under rating
migrations and in that i had given this
entry i had given the path to my rating
solidity file and i had initialized my
smart contract with three movies star
wars avatar and inception and given some
predefined gas
now once these steps are done and i know
the address at which my contract is
deployed i will copy that
and paste it
in the file of ethereum setup.js which
is lying under my rating app ui source
folder and i'll just change this address
now once this rating address is changed
i have to go back to my movie rating app
folder under app ui i have to give the
command npm start
now my application is up and running on
localhost 3000 and as you see i'm able
to do the voting and at each rating
level
my block is gonna increase block six
inception block seven and as and when my
rating is increasing a block is getting
added so this demonstrates the usage of
truffle and ganache in order to build
your decentralized app wow blockchain is
amazing thanks for explaining these
things to me i'm glad i could help you
thanks saurabh now we have rahul to help
you guys understand cryptocurrencies i'm
rahul from simply learn and this is
cryptocurrency explained since man
evolved currency has been a very
important part of our lives in the
caveman era they use the barter system
now the barter system involves goods and
services being exchanged among each
other so now we have a situation where a
caveman is exchanging seven apples and
getting oranges in return now the barter
system fell out of use because it had
some glaring flaws now these flaws
include having people's requirements
coincide for example say you have five
apples and your friend has five oranges
you want some of his oranges now until
and unless your friend has a requirement
for the apples that you own he'll not be
ready to make in exchange for it there's
no common measure of value now since
there's no common measure in terms of
which value of a commodity can be
expressed there's a problem when you
have to decide how many apples you're
ready to trade for one orange or a mango
not all goods can be divided or
subdivided for example you can't divide
a live animal into different smaller
units the goods cannot be transported
easily now unlike how modern currency
fits in your wallet or your mobile phone
the goods that you own cannot be taken
with you everywhere you go after
realizing that the barter system didn't
work very well currency went through a
few iterations in 110 bc an official
currency was minted in thousand 250 a.d
gold plated florence was introduced and
this was used across europe and from
1680 to 1980 paper currency gained
widespread popularity and was used
across the world this is how modern
currency as we know it came into
existence modern currency included paper
currency in coins credit cards and
digital wallets for example you have
apple pay amazon pay paytm paypal and so
on all of this was controlled by banks
and governments now this means that
there was a centralized regulatory
authority that limited how paper
currency and credit cards worked now
imagine the scenario of doing an online
transaction here you're thanking your
friend for paying for your lunch and
you're saying that you're sending them
money to their account now this
transaction takes place successfully but
there are several ways where this could
have gone wrong there could have been a
technical issue at the bank for example
their systems could have been down the
machines weren't working properly and so
on that means there's a central point of
failure which is the bank the users
accounts could have gotten hacked for
example there could have been a ddos
attack or identity theft and so on or
the transfer limits for that account
were exceeded this is why the future of
currency lies with cryptocurrency now
imagine the transaction between two
people in the future one of them has the
bitcoin app and there's a notification
asking whether they're sure they're
ready to transfer five bitcoins if yes
processing takes place here we're
authenticating the user's identity
checking whether they have the required
balance to make that transaction and
other things now after that's done the
payment is transferred and the payment
is received all of this happens in a
matter of minutes and is as simple as
that this in turn removes all the
problems of modern banking there's no
limits to the funds you can transfer
your accounts cannot be hacked and
there's no central point of failure now
as of 2018 there's more than 1600
cryptocurrencies available now there are
some popular ones like bitcoin litecoin
ethereum and zcash and a new
cryptocurrency crops up every single day
now considering how much growth they're
having at the moment there's a good
chance there's plenty more to come in
the upcoming years so what exactly is
cryptocurrency a cryptocurrency is a
digital or virtual currency that is
meant to be a medium of exchange now
cryptocurrency is quite similar to real
world currency just that it does not
have any physical embodiment it also
uses cryptography to work the way it
does now some of the features of
cryptocurrency are that there's a limit
to how many units can exist with bitcoin
this limit exists at 21 million now
after this no more bitcoins will be
produced you can easily verify the
transfer of funds now the hashing
algorithms that bitcoin uses makes it
very easy for users to determine whether
a transaction is valid or not they
operate independent of a bank or a
central authority they work in a
decentralized manner now new units can
be added only after certain conditions
are met for example for bitcoin only
after block has been added to the
blockchain will the miner be rewarded
with bitcoins and this is the only way
new bitcoins can be generated so what
makes cryptocurrency so special firstly
there's little to no transaction costs
now if you use the digital wallet you'll
know that if you're transferring money
from your wallet to your bank account
you'll lose some amount of money you
have 24 7 access to money you can't just
walk up to your bank at 3am in the
morning and say that you want to
withdraw some money there's no limits on
purchases and withdrawals there's
freedom for anyone to use for example if
you're setting up an account in your
bank you need to do some amount of
paperwork and documentation with
cryptocurrencies all of that can be
avoided international transactions are
faster now wire transfers take about
half a day to transfer money from one
place to another but with
cryptocurrencies it only takes a matter
of minutes or seconds what's the crypto
in cryptocurrencies crypto refers to
cryptography it's a method of using
encryption and decryption to secure
communication in the presence of third
parties with ill intent now this refers
to third parties who want to steal your
data or want to eavesdrop on your
conversation cryptography uses
computational algorithms like ssj256
which is the hashing algorithm that
bitcoin uses a public key which is like
a digital identity of the user which he
shares with everyone and a private key
which is the digital signature of the
user which he keeps hidden now let's
talk about a normal bitcoin transaction
first you have the transaction details
now this details who you want to send it
to and how much bitcoins you want to
send them then it's passed through a
hashing algorithm for bitcoin we use the
ssj256 algorithm the output that you
obtain is passed through a signature
algorithm with the user's private key
now this is used to uniquely identify
the user this output is then distributed
across the network for people to verify
this is done by using the sender's
public key the people who verify the
transaction to check whether it's valid
or not are known as miners now after
this is done the transaction and several
others are added to the blockchain where
it cannot be changed again if the
concepts of hashing seem a little
difficult to you i would suggest you
click on the top right corner and watch
the blockchain explain video so that you
can understand better now the sha-256
algorithm like i told you earlier looks
something like this
now seeing how complicated it looks i'm
sure it's safe to say that the
encryption is very difficult to hack
today we'll be focusing on two major
cryptocurrencies bitcoin and ether now
bitcoin is a digital currency that is
decentralized and works on the
blockchain technology it uses a
peer-to-peer network to perform
transactions let's talk about ether
ether is a currency that's accepted in
the ethereum network now the ethereum
network uses blockchain technology to
create an open source platform for
building and deploying decentralized
applications now let's talk about the
similarities between bitcoin and ether
they are the biggest and most valuable
cryptocurrencies in the market right now
both of them use blockchain technology
but is nothing but a technology that
involves transactions being added to a
container called block and creating a
chain of blocks in which data cannot be
altered currency is mined using a method
called proof of work which is a form of
mathematical puzzle that needs to be
solved before a block can be added to
the blockchain finally these are widely
used across the world now let's talk
about the differences with bitcoin it is
used to send money to someone this is
very similar to how real life currency
works with ether it is used as a
currency within the ethereum network
although it can be used for real-life
transactions as well bitcoin
transactions are manual which means you
have to personally perform these
transactions with ether you have the
option to make these transactions manual
or automatic or programmable which means
that these transactions will take place
when a certain condition has been met
for bitcoin it takes 10 minutes to
perform a transaction which is the
amount of time it takes for a block to
be added to the blockchain with ether it
takes about 20 seconds to do a
transaction now blockchain is used like
money for real-world transactions and
ether is used to power the ethereum
network and power real-life transactions
as well ether is used as fuel within the
ethereum network to power both of these
things now there's a limit to how many
bitcoins can exist which is 21 million
we're supposed to hit this number by the
year 2140 ether is expected to be around
for a while but not to exceed 100
million units now bitcoin is used for
transactions involving goods and
services and ether uses blockchain
technology to create a ledger to trigger
a transaction when a certain condition
is met for bitcoin we use an algorithm
called sha-256 for hashing and with
ethereum we use et hash as of july 23
2018 one bitcoin equals
hundred and sixty eight dollars for
ether it costs four hundred and sixty
four dollars now what's the future of
cryptocurrencies the whole world is
clearly divided when it comes to
cryptocurrencies on one side you have
supporters like bill gates al gore and
richard branson who say that
cryptocurrencies are better than regular
currencies on the other side we have
people completely against it people like
warren buffet paul krugman and richard
schiller who are both nobel prize
winners in the field of economics they
call it a ponzi scheme and means for
criminal activities in the future
there's going to be a conflict between
regulation and anonymity since several
cryptocurrencies have been linked with
terrorist attacks governments would want
to regulate how cryptocurrencies would
work ethereum so now let's take a look
what's in it for all of us today we will
be talking about what is ethereum the
features of ethereum like cryptocurrency
smart contracts ethereum virtual machine
decentralized application and it uses
and decentralized autonomous
organization we'll be also looking at
applications of ethereum and a demo on
smart contract deployment on a locally
running ethereum client now what is
ethereum ethereum is a blockchain based
computing platform that enables
developers to build and deploy these
centralized applications so basically
ethereum is a platform where we can
build applications which are not run by
a centralized authority you can create a
decentralized application where the
participants of that particular
application are the decision making
authority so here we can see ethereum
allows us to build and deploy dap
applications now what are the typical
features of ethereum ethereum allows you
to use its own cryptocurrency called
it allows development and deployment of
smart contracts it provides you the
underlying technology the architecture
the software which understands smart
contracts and allow you to interact with
it which is called ethereum virtual
machine then it allows eventually to
create consolidated applications called
decentralized applications and also it
allows you to create decentralized
autonomous organization now let's talk
about ethereum cryptocurrency ether eth
is a cryptocurrency that runs on
ethereum network basically it is the
fuel which is running the ethereum
network it is used to pay for the
computational resources and the
transaction fees for any transaction to
be executed on an ethereum network like
bitcoin ether is also a peer-to-peer
currency apart from paying for
transaction ether is also used to buy
gas which is used to pay for computation
of any transaction you make on an
ethereum network also if you have to
deploy a contract on ethereum network
you will need gas and you would have to
pay for that gas in ethers so gas is the
execution fee paid by a user for running
a transaction in ethereum ether can be
utilized for building decentralized
applications for building your smart
contracts and making standard
peer-to-peer payments now what is a
smart contract a smart contract is a
simple computer program that facilitates
the exchange of any valuable asset
between two parties it could be money it
could be shares it could be property or
it could be any other digital asset
which you want to exchange these
contracts can be created by anyone on
the ethereum network and primarily the
contract consists of the terms and
conditions mutually agreed between the
parties between the peers and the
primary feature of a smart contract is
that once it is executed it cannot be
altered and any transaction done on top
of a smart contract is registered
permanently it is immutable so even in
future you modify the smart contract the
transactions correlated with the
original contract does not get altered
or you cannot modify them so for the
verification process smart contract is
carried out amongst the anonymous
parties of the network without the need
of a centralized authority and that's
what makes any smart contract execution
on ethereum a decentralized execution it
provides the transfer of any asset or
currency in a transparent and a
trustworthy manner as the two entities
are totally unaware their identity is
secure on the ethereum network though
the transactions weren't successfully
done the accounts of the sender and
receiver are updated accordingly and
there's why it generates a trust between
the parties who are transacting using
the ethereum network now what happens in
traditional system of contract in
traditional systems of contract you sign
an agreement then you trust a third
party hire a third party for execution
now the problem is that in such an
engagement the data tampering is
possible now if we talk about the new
smart contract the agreement is coded in
a program now result is not verified by
a centralized authority it is verified
by the participants on ethereum based
blockchain network now once a contract
is executed the transaction is
registered and it cannot be altered or
tampered so it removes the risk of any
data manipulation or alteration now
let's take another example where zac has
given a contract of 500
to elsa for developing his company's
website now the developers code the
agreement of smart contract using
ethereum's programming language now the
smart contract has all the conditions
the requirements for building the
website once the code is written it is
uploaded and deployed on the ethereum
evm virtual machine evm is a runtime
compiler to execute your smart contract
once the code is deployed on the evm
every participant on the network has a
copy of the contract now now when elsa
submits the work on ethereum for
evaluation each node on the ethereum
network will evaluate and confirm
whether the result given by elsa is done
as per the coding requirements and once
approved and verified the contract worth
will be self-executed and the payment
will be paid to elsa in ethers so john's
account the person who had gone into a
contract his account will be
automatically debited and elsa will be
credited with 500 in ether denomination
here we will now take a look we will do
a demo small demo on a deployment of a
smart contract so for in order to
execute our smart contract we will need
two set of softwares ganache and truffle
and we will show you in the demo how to
install these two softwares on your
machine now we will be giving a demo on
the following smart contract this is a
smart contract where we are writing a
simple contract of a greeter we have a
variable called greeting which we will
be initializing using a constructor and
then in our demo we will be showing how
you can change the value of the variable
greeting using the setgridding method
and read the value using the greet
method this is the other contract where
we will be defining that whoever is
deploying the contract on the blockchain
network is always the owner of the
contract and then we have defined
certain mandatory functions in order to
kill the contract on the ethereum
network so only the owner of the
contract can kill it now let's talk
about what is an ethereum virtual
machine each virtual machine is designed
to operate as a runtime environment for
compiling and deploying ethereum based
smart contracts basically evm is the
engine which understands the language of
smart contracts which are written in
solidity language for ethereum evm is
operated in a sandbox environment
basically you can deploy your own
standalone environment which can act as
a testing and a development environment
and you can n number of times test your
smart contract deploy it verify it and
then once you are satisfied with the
performance and the functionality of the
smart contract you can deploy it on the
ethereum main net now any programming
language in the smart contract is
compiled into the byte code which the
evm understands this byte code can be
read and executed you using an ethereum
feature called ethereum virtual machine
so basically evm machine understands a
byte code so one of the most popular
languages for writing a smart contract
is solidity so once you write your smart
contract on solidity that contract gets
converted into the byte code and gets
deployed on the ev and thereby evm
guarantees security from cyber attack
now how does evm work so suppose a wants
to pay b 10 ethers the transaction will
be sent to the evm using a smart
contract for a funds transfer from a to
b now in order to validate the
transaction the ethereum network will
perform the proof of work consensus
algorithm the minor nodes on the
ethereum will validate this transaction
whether the first the identity of a
exist or not a has the relevant amount
of balance to transfer 10 ether to b and
in will validate the transaction once
validated the ether will be debited from
a's wallet and will be credited to b's
wallet and during this course the miners
will charge a fees in order to validate
this transaction and will earn a reward
now all the nodes on ethereum network
execute smart contract using their
respective evms now how does proof of
work works every node in the ethereum
network has the entire history of all
the transactions the entire chain it has
the history of smart contract with
basically the address at which the smart
contract is deployed the transactions
associated with the smart contract and
also it has the handle to the current
state of the smart contract now the goal
of the miners on the ethereum blockchain
network is to validate the block for
each block of transaction miners use the
computational power and resources to get
the appropriate hash value by varying
the nonce now the miners will vary the
nonce and pass it through a hashing
algorithm in case of ethereum it is the
it hash algorithm this produces a hash
value which should be lesser than the
predefined target as per the proof of
work consensus if the hash value
generated is less than the target value
then only the block is considered to be
verified and the miner gets rewarded
only then now when the proof of work is
solved result is broadcasted and shared
with all the other nodes in order to
update their ledger if other nodes
accept the hash block as valid then the
block gets added to the ethereum mainnet
blockchain and as a result the miner
receives a reward which as of today
stands at three ethers plus the miner
receives the transaction fees which has
been generated for verifying the block
all the transactions which are
aggregated in the block the cumulative
transaction fees associated with all the
transactions is also rewarded to the
miner now do you know in ethereum a
process called proof of stake is also
under development and it is an
alternative to proof of work it is meant
to be a solution to minimize the use of
expensive resources you spend for mining
using proof of work now in proof of
stake the miner is actually the
validator can validate the transactions
based on the amount of crypto coins he
or she holds before he or she can start
the mining so based on the accumulation
or the repository of crypto coins with
the miner beforehand will give him the
higher probability of mining the block
now however proof of stake is not widely
adopted as of now as compared to proof
of work algorithm now let's understand
the concept of gas now ethereum virtual
machine has a concept of gas and why do
we need it so like we need fuel to run
car in the same way in order to run
application on ethereum network we need
gas now what is gas to perform any
transactional ethereum network a user
has to make a payment has to shell out
ethers in order to get the execution
done the transaction done and the
intermediary monetary value is called as
gas on ethereum network gas is a unit
that measures the computational power
required to run a smart contract or a
transaction so if you have to do a
transaction which is updating the
blockchain you would have to shell out
gas and that gas will come with the
price in ethers now how is the gas fees
calculated in ethereum the transaction
fees is calculated in ethereum using the
below formula for every transaction
there is a gas and the correlated gas
price so the amount of gas required to
execute a transaction multiplied by the
gas price you generate the transaction
fees so gas limit on ethereum network
refers to the amount of gas which is
used for the computation and the amount
of ether a user is required to pay for
the gas now here we have a screenshot
from the ethereum mainnet where the cost
of transaction is being shown so if you
see for this particular example
transaction the gas limit was 21 000 the
gas used by the transaction was 21 000
and the gas price was 21 gui which is
the lowest denomination so 21
gui into 21 000 gave you the actual
transaction fees which is
0.00441 ether which is approximately
0.21 cents as of today's ether market
value now this transaction fee goes to
the miner who has validated the
transaction to understand the gas limit
and the gas price in a better way let's
consider an example of a car suppose
your car has a mileage of 10 kilometers
and the price of petrol is one dollar
per liter then driving a car for 50
kilometers will cost you five liters of
patrol which will be worth five dollars
similarly to perform an operation or to
run a code on ethereum you need to
obtain certain amount of gas like the
patrol where each gas has a per unit
price called gas price now if the user
provides less amount of gas to run a
particular operation then the process
will fail and the user will be given a
message of out of gas and gui is the
lowest denomination of ether which is
used for measuring unit of a gas price
now how is ethereum's mining different
from bitcoin mining the hashing
algorithm is the primary difference the
bitcoin uses sha-256 ethereum uses it
hash the average time taken on bitcoin
for mining a block is 10 minutes whereas
in ethereum it is 12 to 15 seconds as of
today the mining reward for bitcoin is
12.5 btc but for ethereum is this three
ethers plus the transaction fee the
accumulated transaction fee for all the
transactions for a block now as of 23rd
july the bitcoin value was seven
thousand six hundred and sixty seven
dollars whereas one ether stands at 466
dollars now here we have a screenshot of
ethereum reward which has been given to
the miner of the block now as you can
see here is the breakup of the reward
three ethers plus the total accumulated
transaction fee of all the underlying
transactions in this block which is
0.0666 ethos now what is a decentralized
application now let's compare it with
our traditional applications our
traditional websites which are currently
running so for example when you log into
twitter a web application gets displayed
which is rendered using an html page now
the page will call an api to access your
personal data your information which is
centrally hosted now it's a simple
process your front end executes a
backend api and the api goes and fetches
the information from a centralized db
now if we transform this application
into a decentralized application then
now when you will log in the same web
application will get rendered but it
will be calling a smart contract based
api to fetch the information from the
blockchain network so the api gets
replaced with the smart contract
interface and the smart contract will
fetch the information from the
blockchain network which is its backend
and that blockchain network is not a
centralized db it's a decentralized
network where the participants of the
network the miners of the network are
validating verifying all the
transactions which are happening using
the smart contract on the blockchain
network so thereby any now any
transaction or any action happening on
the twitter kind of application which
has been transformed will now cannot be
claimed as a centralized uh transaction
it will be a decentralized transaction a
dap a decentralized application consists
of back-end code that runs on a
distributed peer-to-peer network it is a
software designed to work on an ethereum
network without being controlled by a
centralized system and that is the
primary difference it provides the
direct interaction between the end users
and the decentralized application
providers now an application qualifies
as dap when it is open sourced its code
is there on github and it uses a public
blockchain based token in order to run
the application a token acts as a fuel
for the decentralized application to run
dap allows the backend code and data to
be decentralized and that is the primary
architecture of any dap now let's
discuss what are decentralized
autonomous organizations daos is a
digital organizations that wants to
operate without any need of a
hierarchical management it wants to
operate in a decentralized and a
democratized fashion so basically a dao
is an organization where the
decision-making should not be in the
hands of a centralized authority but it
should be in the hands of certain
designated authorities or a group of
designated people as a part of authority
it exists on a blockchain network where
it is governed by the protocols embedded
in a smart contract and thereby they
rely on a smart contract for decision
making all the business decisions are
driven by the smart contracts or we can
say a decentralized voting system within
the organization so any organizational
decision before being taken has to go
through the voting system which is
running on a decentralized application
so how it work people add funds to the
dow because dao requires funding in
order to execute and take decisions
based on that each member is given a
token on a percentage basis which
represents the percentage of shares of
that particular member in the dow now
those tokens are used to vote in the dow
where the proposal status is decided
based on the maximum votes so every
decision within the organization has to
go through this voting process now let's
take a look what are the applications of
ethereum in real world and where it is
getting used so as we have seen with dao
voting systems are adopting it the
results of the polls are publicly
available where it ensures a transparent
and fair democracy by eliminating voting
malpractices it is getting adopted
widely in a banking scenarios and
banking systems with ethereum's
decentralized system it is becoming very
difficult for hackers to have
unauthorized access and it also allows
payments on an ethereum based network so
banks are also using ethereum as a
channel to make remittances and payments
shipping deploying ethereum and shipping
helps tracking of cargo and prevents
goods from being misplaced or
counterfeited so basically ethereum is
providing you of the provenance and
tracking framework for any kind of asset
required in a typical supply chain now
with ethereum's smart contract
agreements can be maintained and
executed without any alteration so any
industry which has fragmented
participants is subject to disputes and
which requires and digital contracts to
be present then ethereum can definitely
be used as a technology for developing
your smart contract and digitally
recording the agreements and the
transactions based on those agreements
so let's get started for a demo
on how to deploy
an ethereum smart contract locally so in
order to deploy a smart contract we will
be first installing
ganache client which allows you to host
a local ethereum client on which you can
deploy your smart contract so as we are
working on the windows environment when
we are downloading the ganache setup
we can also download
node order to install truffle on our
machines
now as the node has been downloaded we
will install node
so now node is successfully installed
now we are going to install ganache
locally
now we will run ganache a little later
before that we will perform certain
steps or we can run ganache and see
so once ganache is up and running i'll
show you the interface how it looks
so when ganache
is brought up it automatically creates
10 accounts with pre-funded balance of
100 ethers it is running on localhost
port number
7545 now as you see there is no
transaction or anything which has
currently happened so the current block
is 0 which is the genesis block there
are no transactions and there are no
blocks as of now so there are no
transactions in block which have been
generated so using this ganache client
now we will be deploying our greeter
contract now as we have installed node
we will be installing truffle ruffle is
the utility which allows us to compile
and deploy
ethereum contracts
okay now once a truffle is installed
we need to create a directory called
greeter
now we need to run the command truffle
now once we run this command
ruffle by default
creates a package structure which has
three folders called contracts
migrations test truffle.js and
truffleconfig now we will be writing our
smart contract called greeter.soul
and we will compile and deploy basically
our
greater.soul
will be under contracts folder and we
can
our contract is created and it is lying
under contracts folder now we need to
add another file under migrations folder
called as deploy contract.js
so we will name it as deploy contract
now in this
deploy contract we need to put line of
code now in this file we are asking
truffle to deploy our newly created
greeter.soul file now in the greater
contract we have a constructor we are
initializing the greater contract with a
value high hello and we are passing a
gas value so this gas is currently at a
higher limits and we know that this gas
value the contract will get executed but
otherwise you can also evaluate the gas
value of a contract using remix now once
this file has been saved you go to the
truffle.js
and make the following entry
now here we are telling truffle that our
localhost ganache client is running on
localhost at port number 7545
and network id can be anything though
the current ganache client is running on
port network id five triple seven but we
have kept it open that we can connect to
any network id now after this step i
need to go back to my command prompt and
say
referral
compile
now if you get this error if we are
getting this kind of error in windows
then we need to do one quick fix
we need to go to the users directory and
rename truffle.cmd to trough so i'll go
to my drive
users
just
now here now instead of truffle i have
to say trough
now there might be certain compilation
warnings we can ignore that now my
contract has been compiled now i need to
run the next command trough my great
at this stage my smart contract is
deployed and now you can see
this is the step this is the place where
the contract has been called and this is
the transaction where
the
default value of my variable greeter has
been set to high hello so we will see
now i need to run command trough console
to interact with my contract now as on
my craft console
i can check at what address is my
contract deployed so my contract is
deployed at address
0x37 which matches with the address
0x373
now
i need to check
the default value which i had set while
deploying my contract so this is my
value hi hello now i can
change the value to something else
because in my greater contract i have a
method called
set greeting now whenever when i'll be
performing this action
a new block will get generated and the
block count will increase from 4 to 5
because i'm making a change on the
blockchain as you can see now a new
transaction has been created this was
the gas used this is the default gas
price in ganache and block number five
has been mined now i can re-read the
value of the variable now it will return
me latest value which is change greet
value so this demonstrates
how to use
a solidity contract how to compile it
deploy it on a locally running
blockchain network you can connect
multiple nodes to this ganache client
and all the nodes should be running on
the same network id should have the same
network id but they can be running on a
different machine so here we can see all
the other details the block the
transactions which have happened if i
perform the action again
number six has been generated has
another transaction associated with it
and i can get the latest value so let's
get started and understand what is a
smart contract what's in it for us today
let's understand why do we need a smart
contract what is a smart contract usage
of solidity for building smart contract
advantages of smart contract blockchain
implementation of smart contracts we
look at certain examples of voting and
digital token and also we will take
another use case of how smart contracts
help us do crowdfunding now why smart
contract now let's take a look
traditionally how contracts used to
happen if suppose two parties a and b
have to get into a contract they will
utilize the services of a third party
whom they have to trust and get the
contract executed now with the
introduction of smart contracts and the
technology which is evolving removes the
dependency on such third parties and
automates the execution of such smart
contracts so if we compare traditional
versus the new smart contract in
traditional we used to have governments
lawyers or any other third party on
which we can trust in smart contracts we
don't need any third party we don't need
any intermediate execution time
definitely there's higher execution time
in traditional contracts because as many
number of middlemen and their
intermediary layers that many number of
days and time it takes smart contract is
just a matter of minutes it gets
executed because it is automated
programmable running on a computer and
it has some predefined condition
remittance if any remittance of either
of the parties have to happen then it's
a manual process approvals workflows
processes
and these manual processes take time
under traditional contracting system but
in a smart contract as the conditions
are predefined pre-embedded as soon as a
condition is met the remittance happens
automatically either of the parties who
have to be credited with an amount is
credited automatically and that is the
primary advantage of using a smart
contract transparency
is not available 100 in traditional
contracts the transparency is bound
peripheral between the parties and the
entities and the intermediaries involved
as compared to smart contract
transparency is 100 available 24x7
online anyone can go and review audit
and validate the transactions executed
by the smart contracts archiving
archiving is a big difficult problem for
traditional contracts as most of the
transactions are paper-based or the
records are maintained offline it
becomes very difficult to maintain and
identify the traceability provenance of
all the transactions which have happened
in a traditional contract whereby in a
smart contract it becomes easy as all
the transactions have happened through
the smart contract there's a hundred
percent traceability available from the
provenance point of view you can trace
the transaction from its day one the
point of origin till present day and
archiving is automatically happening the
log the audit the transaction history is
automatically getting generated security
definitely is a concern in traditional
contracts as the intermediaries and
involved manual processes involved
security can be compromised at any level
at any stage but in a smart contract the
security is maintained through
cryptography mainly through public key
infrastructure the public and private
key infrastructure it is a very secure
way of maintaining security and
cryptography of the transactions using a
smart contract cost yes traditional
contracts are expensive the cost of
transaction is high as compared to smart
contracts as the middlemen are involved
smart contract the cost is low as we
don't have any intermediaries and only
the cost of transaction is charged by
the underlying infrastructure of the
blockchain network which is running the
smart contracts signatures its manual
process all the transactions are signed
manually and verified manually but here
in the smart contracts all the
transactions are digitally signed using
the private key of the entities and can
only be decoded by the public key shared
by the parties involved in the smart
contract so in a nutshell smart
contracts give us n number of advantages
the primary advantages are listed here
and these are the advantages which
enforce us to move towards an economy
and to a system where we start using
smart contracts for our transactions to
avoid any disputes to keep the
transaction cost low thereby giving the
advantage to the end consumer now what
is a smart contract let's consider a
real life example where you are taking
out a chocolate from a vending machine
you deposit a two dollar note in a
vending machine after that you hit a1
button which is mapped against the
chocolate bar that you want to buy as a
result a liver in the vending machine
moves and pushes out the chocolate so
basically even button is programmed to
the lever in order to move the chocolate
out now a smart contract is very similar
to a vending machine it eliminates the
need of an intermediary in case of the
vending machine is replacing a direct
seller and allowing you to make a
purchase without a middleman and it
eliminates the need of escrow services
now smart contracts are self-executing
contract which contain the terms and
conditions of an agreement between the
parties and the peers who are involved
in that english so the terms and
conditions of an agreement are written
in a piece of code and it is executed on
a blockchain based decentralized
platform now these agreements
facilitates exchange of any digital
asset it could be digital currency it
could be shares it could be property or
it could be anything which you want to
transact so a blockchain based
decentralized platform gives you a
democratic system where the transactions
are authorized by the majority of the
participants and the identity of the
participants is also kept anonymous now
let's consider an example where rachel
is at the airport and her flight is
delayed but this inconvenience could
have been beneficial to richard as smart
contract insurance would ensure she is
given a compensation for the flight's
delay instantly so just imagine there is
a smart contract which the insurance
company has already deployed and it's
monitoring the flights delay rachel has
already taken that insurance for delay
in flights so as soon as that condition
is met for a delay of flight above x
amount of hours for example two hours
then in that case the insurance company
will automatically get that trigger and
rachel will be credited with that amount
for which she is insured in her account
so let's see how smart contract can be
helpful here so axa flight delay
insurance is one of the examples of
ethereum smart contract axa is an
insurance company the smart contract is
linked to the databases that record
flight status so that smart contract is
connected to the databases it is
fetching that information and evaluating
the delay it enables automatic
compensation when there is a delay for
two hours or more so that is the
condition when the flight delay is
beyond to ours then the insurance
contract will get executed and rachel
will get paid a smart contract is
created based on the terms and
conditions so condition compensation is
equal to flight delay is less than two
hours based on the code smart contract
holds the company's money until a
certain condition is satisfied this
smart contract is submitted to the nodes
on the blockchain network to their evms
for evaluation so evm is a runtime
compiler to execute smart contracts code
it is the brain it is the electronic
virtual machine which executes the smart
contract all nodes on the network
executing the code using the evm must
come to the same result because all the
evms would have the same copy of the
smart contract deployed if the flight is
delayed two or more hours smart contract
will be self-executed and the
compensation amount will be given to
rachel and that is the objective of the
smart contract without involvement of
any middleman paperwork which rachel has
to do to submit and then the insurance
company going through the manual process
all that has been bypassed and rachel
has been compensated directly now let's
understand why do we need solidity for
developing our smart contracts now here
comes the important question which
programming language does a smart
contract use there are two widely used
programming languages for writing
ethereum smart contracts solidity and
serpent however on blockchain platforms
solidity is widely used for implementing
smart contracts and this is what we were
going to talk about in our subsequent
slides now solidity is a high level
programming language used for
implementing smart contracts it enables
to check the program at runtime rather
than compile time solidity is a turing
complete language it has all the
conditions all the while loops for root
operators etc which are there in any
mature programming language in order to
write your code in order to write your
conditions if you have certain loop if
you have while conditions etc now what
are the advantages of smart contract as
we have already discussed there are no
intermediaries involved the process
executes without the need of a third
party it's an automated process they are
automated with the code which eliminates
manual effort for execution it's a high
speed highly computative smart contracts
which runs on programming code the speed
of its execution is higher than a
traditional contract as the data is
stored in the decentralized system the
chances of modifying the data is
difficult and i would say more than
impossible accuracy based on the
requirements terms and condition of a
contract is recorded accurately so as
soon as any transaction is recorded it
is registered on a blockchain network
and it is immutable transaction no one
can modify or make changes in any record
which has been added onto a blockchain
network through a smart contract now
let's take a look at certain blockchain
implementation of a smart contract using
blockchain in voting process
can eliminate voting malpractices a
centralized voting system faces a lot of
problems when it comes to tracking votes
there could be manipulated identities
there could be manipulation in counting
there could be biased decision making a
smart contract is introduced to
eliminate all these malpractices there
are certain predefined terms and
conditions which are already set in the
contract no voter can vote from a
digital identity of any other voter the
counting is full proof every vote is
registered on a blockchain network and
the accounting is happening
automatically without any interference
from a third party or dependency on a
manual process so terms and condition
each id should be attributed to just one
vote the validation is done by the users
on the blockchain network itself so the
voting process can be in a public
blockchain or it could be in a
decentralized autonomous
organization-based blockchain setup also
but it is 100 transparent and every
voting transaction is recorded result
every voters would get recorded on the
ledger and that information cannot be
modified it is transparently publicly
available for audit and verification now
let's take a look at one of the examples
of our voting solidity contract so here
we have our voting solidity contract it
is built in solidity and i'll just give
you a brief overview of what are the
primary functions in this so if we look
at this particular contract this
contract gives you certain basic
parameters like what should be the
minimum number of participants or
proposals which are required for voting
then what should be the minimum amount
of time for debate that needs to pass
before the vote can be executed then the
margin of votes for majority a proposal
passes if there are more than 50 percent
of the votes plus the margin so
basically we are defining what is the
winning condition what is the majority
margin for any word to be accepted then
you have data structure where you are
accepting the proposals right and then
subsequently we are defining data
structures for members who are
participating in the proposals who are
submitting the proposals we are fetching
the addresses of the members basically
this is the digital identity of the
members who are submitting the proposals
and etc so the smart contracts basically
allows you to create a voting system
where you can add members we can remove
the members you can change certain
voting rules based on certain conditions
like if you want to increase the minimum
quorum if you want to change the
debating period minutes or the majority
rule changes then this is a function for
submitting a new proposal for which the
voting has to happen so basically this
example is about if i have to take a
vote within a decentralized autonomous
organization for a particular decision
so rather than a central authority
taking a decision you can have a voting
mechanism within your organization to
give a majority to your proposal if you
get the majority the proposal is
accepted otherwise reject then there are
peripheral functions like check proposal
code then there is a voting function the
actual vote happens and for a particular
proposal you start increasing or
decreasing the number of votes then you
execute the proposal if the majority has
been achieved now let's take a look on
how to deploy a smart contract so here
we have our voting smart contract now we
will take a look on how to deploy our
voting smart contract on the ethereum
test network called robston this is our
voting smart contract now when you open
remix you should also have meta mask
which is a chrome plugin installed this
is a utility in order to connect to the
robston test net which is an ethereum
test network so basically you say
option.etherscan.io and this is the
ethereum test network on which we will
deploy our contract so once you log in
into the metamask you will have a
account created and in that account you
should have some test ethers already so
that you can use them to deploy your
contract so when you create an account
on uh robsten you can buy certain ethers
using the robston test faucet
so when you reach this site that option
test faucet has already taken the
address for the account for which you
are raising the request and you can
raise request of one ether now whenever
this transaction will get processed your
account balance will get incremented by
one so as i already have ethers in it i
can utilize it to deploy my contract now
in order to compile and deploy my
contract i have copy pasted it here and
if i go to my run my remix has already
communicated via injected web 3 to the
meta mask and taken my account which has
7.83 ether
now i need to do some settings
now as my contract is compiled you can
see it has taken all the contracts you
can see the drop down and congress is my
major contract now i will deploy my
contract so on the run section you will
be able to see in the drop down the name
of the contracts which are there in my
smart contract like i had owned token
recipient then there's an interface and
there is a congress so i need to deploy
my congress contract now in order to
deploy this contract there is a
constructor which requires certain
inputs so i can give certain values like
what minimum number of proposals i need
100 then minimum number of debates 10
and margin of votes for majority so i
said deploy now as soon as i'll click
deploy it is going to request me for gas
because when the contract gets deployed
it will deduct certain ethers from my
account so when i'll say submit
if you notice now this transaction has
got initiated on the robsten
etherscan.io i click on it so this is
the transaction on which the contract is
getting deployed it is taking time and
the contract is getting processed on the
ethereum network now once it will get
deployed we will be able to see the
address at which the contract has got
created and deployed now as you can see
my contract has got deployed at the
address 0xcc i can load it now this is
the contract address and this is the
amount of actual ether which was spent
from my account in order to deploy the
contract
now there are certain attributes on the
option ether scan which you can go and
check you can verify and publish your
smart contract over here so that others
can also view the code and utilize your
smart contract and if you go and check
your meta mask this is the transaction
which has just been done in your account
and if you click it will take you to the
same transaction which we opened here
now after you have deployed the contract
you can interact with your contract
directly through remix just to test your
contract all the pink members are the
ones which make changes onto the
blockchain and all the blue ones are the
ones which are only performing read
operations so in order to do any read
operation you will not be requested to
spend any gas so there will be no
pop-ups for metamask requesting for gas
spending but if you do any of these pink
actions then you will be required to
spend gas as it will be requiring to
make some changes onto the blockchain so
this was a example of a voting smart
contract and this will be available as a
link for you to take a look now all our
other contracts which we will be
covering subsequently will be deployed
in a similar fashion on the robstone
test net now let's take another example
if you want to use smart contract to
issue your own cryptocurrency or called
digital token you can use ethereum based
smart contract to create your own
digital tokens for performing
transactions a design and issue your own
digital currency create a tradable
computerized token that can be utilized
as a currency share or any asset which
you want to transact these tokens use a
standard coin api like in case of
ethereum we have standardizations of
erc20 etc which allows contract to
automatically access any wallet for
exchange as a result you build a
tradable token with a suffix supply and
this particular platform becomes like a
central bank issuing a digital money
your smart contract becomes the bank
issuing the money so let's take this
example here so this is a implementation
of a erc20 token which is a
specification by ethereum and
the primary attribute for this token is
that you need to provide a name of your
token a symbol the decimals to which you
support and the most primary is the
predefined supply so just like in an
economy you have limited supply of money
here also you have to define what will
be the supply of your tokens and it will
be capped that will be the supply so you
need to redefine these parameters
and then you create certain data
structures within solidity to keep a tap
on the balances of the entities to which
you are giving the tokens and how much
allowance you want to keep per address
then there are certain methods which you
have to implement as per the erc20
specification like transfer transfer
from approve and call etc so all these
methods in a typical token allows you to
do the transaction send and receive your
custom token among multiple parties so
this would also be available as a link
for you to take a look now let's take
another example of a use case for
crowdfunding using smart contracts to
crowdfund your project so suppose you
want to start a business and for a
business you need a lot of funding which
is required but who would lend that
money to someone whom they don't trust
how will you generate that money for
such problems smart contract plays a
major role with ethereum you can build a
smart contract that will hold a
contributor's funds unless a given date
or a goal is met based on the result the
funds will be released to the contract
owners or will be sent back to the
contributors so basically you can create
a crowdfunding project for yourself if
you want to raise certain amount of
money and the contributors or the
investors will give you the money but
the amount will be kept on hold till the
time your project goal or date has been
met and accordingly the investor will
get you the token which you have
developed for crowdfunding in us or his
account accordingly now centralized
crowdfunding system has plenty of issues
with management systems so therefore a
dow a decentralized autonomous
organization is utilized for
crowdfunding the terms and conditions
are transparently set in the contract
every individual participating in the
funding is given a token and the token
is credited to their ethereum based
account now every contribution gets
recorded on the blockchain because then
the token transfer has happened from the
dow to the individual investor that
transaction get recorded on the
blockchain network so let's uh quickly
take a look at the uh contract for a
crowdsale also so a crowdsale contract
provides you the basic attributes like
what is the goal of the funding how much
money you need to raise what is the
amount raised real time you can keep a
track what is the deadline right and
what is the price of the token in
ethereum basically what is the your
token amount in ethereum then there
could be that you might give certain
tokens in reward then you can have
attributes for your reward and then you
have your methods in order to keep a
check that once you have received the
funds you can withdraw the funds you can
check whether you have reached the goal
for funding and then you have the
methods for transferring tokens from the
sender to your own account this
particular kind of contract allows you
to maintain and keep a check on amount
of funding you have received or you want
to receive have you achieved your target
who are the investors in your token how
much percentage share belongs to your
account and how much percentage share
has been already been distributed on
amongst the investors etc so everything
can be tracked so the smart contract can
build in such a fashion that there are
methods and utilities available in order
to run your entire crowdfunding so this
contract is also available in the link
and you can take a look now that that's
done saurabh will teach us about bitcoin
mining and how bitcoin wallets work so
let's get started and let's talk about
what is bitcoin mining so what is
bitcoin so let's take an example so
there is someone who wants to send five
bitcoins to rachel now we will see how
this transaction can happen now bitcoin
is based on the concept of digital
currency anyone across the globe can
transfer amount in bitcoin irrespective
of the geography from anyone to anyone
so basically you need to just open an
account on the bitcoin network have some
bitcoins in it and you can transfer it
either you can purchase the bitcoins
online through some exchanges or you can
mine it so once you have bitcoins in
your account you can transfer it to
someone you want whose address you have
now do you want to know how this
transaction work well this transaction
is done by bitcoin mining so we will go
deep and understand that
how the bitcoin transaction works what
all entities are involved behind the
scenes in order to maintain the sanity
of the bitcoin network and make sure
that whomever you wanted the bitcoin to
reach to has reached and there is no
loss of bitcoin in the network and it is
a successful transaction so let's
understand certain basics so what's in
it for us today we need to know what is
bitcoin we will understand the
underlying technology blockchain so we
will talk about that then we will see
what are the advantages of bitcoin as
compared to other digital currencies and
other digital technologies then we will
go into the concepts of bitcoin mining
then what is bitcoin mining and we will
do a demo on certain aspects of bitcoin
mining now what is bitcoin bitcoin is
the first decentralized digital currency
that allows users to transfer money
peer-to-peer without any intermediaries
like banks governments agents brokers
nothing is involved and all this is done
using blockchain technology so as we saw
in our previous example two parties
wants to exchange money transfer money
they don't need an intermediary now
bitcoin can be used for online purchases
e-commerce transactions it can be used
as an investment instrument and it can
be primarily used for payments to buy
goods and services now it was created in
2009 it came into existence by a person
or a group of people called satoshi
nakamoto now
bitcoin helps transferring of assets
faster than regular fiat currencies it
has definitely lower transaction fees
because as it has removed the
intermediaries from between the cost of
transaction also goes down and it is
cryptographically secure it uses
cryptography infrastructure and thereby
the identities of the sender and the
receiver are also secure and entire
transaction is cryptographically signed
and the user's information who are doing
the transactions or are part of the
networker is also hidden and secure now
what are the advantages of bitcoin so it
allows fast and quick peer-to-peer
transactions it is impossible to
counterfeit or hack the transactions
which are running on a bitcoin network
and it's an overall decentralized
process there is no centralized body
which is controlling the transactions or
charging a fees in order to validate the
transaction it is the participants in
the decentralized network who are taking
care of the sanity of the network
thereby making sure that the overall
transaction cost is low all the
information is accessible to public it
is available publicly on a public ledger
anyone can go and view the transactions
and the volume of the transactions
happening on the bitcoin network and it
is a low fee transaction it is
comparatively low to other mediums and
channels through which today digital
transactions are made now what is
blockchain so bitcoin runs on the
underlying technology of blockchain
blockchain is a public distributed
ledger in which transactions made in
bitcoins or any other digital currency
are recorded in a chronological order so
let's see certain features it is
cryptographically secure signed using
your private key and then shared on the
network with the public key it is
immutable any record or any transaction
added on the blockchain cannot be
modified or altered it is run by a
decentralized system there is no
centralized authority on the body and
the transactions are stored in
containers aggregated in containers
called blocks so a block is the smallest
unit of a blockchain which records all
the transaction a basic structure of a
block is something like this it has four
fields these are the primary attributes
for block it has something called as
previous hash so the previous hash
attribute stores the value of the hash
of the previous block and that's how the
blocks are linked to each other data
this is the aggregated set of
transactions which are included in this
block so these are the set of
transactions which were mined and
validated and included in the block
nonce so in proof of work consensus
algorithm which is used in bitcoin nonce
is a random value which is used to vary
the output of the hash value so every
block is supposed to generate a hash
value and nonce is the parameter which
is used to generate that hash value and
the proof of work is the process of
transaction verification done in
blockchain now hash is the resultant
hash value obtained by passing the
previous hash value the data and the
nonce through the sha-256 algorithm to
generate the hash of this block so this
is the digital signature of the block
which is generated and this is the
basically identity of this block now
shk-256 is a cryptographic hash
algorithm which produces a unique 256
bit alphanumeric hash value for any
given input and that is the unique
feature of this cryptographic algorithm
whatever input you give it will always
produce a 256-bit hash now let's
understand the concepts of bitcoin
mining what is bitcoin mining bitcoin
mining is the process of verifying
bitcoin transactions and recording them
onto the public blockchain ledger in
blockchain the transactions are verified
by bitcoin users so basically the
transactions have to be verified by none
other than the participants of the
network those who have the required
hardware and computing power and those
entities are called miners so we will be
talking about them later but the point
to be highlighted is that there is
nothing like a centralized body as in
case of legacy transactions where we
used to be dependent on a regulatory or
governing body or a bank to make our
transactions go through now in bitcoin
here any user with mining hardware and
internet access can take apart that kind
of computer can be a participant and
contribute to the mining community
process is solved based on a difficult
mathematical puzzle called proof of work
so every miners job is to solve the
mathematical puzzle which is called
proof of work in order to validate the
transaction and earn the reward and all
the miners as they are competing amongst
themselves to mine a particular
transaction the miner who first solves
the puzzle gets the reward now users
trying to sell the puzzle as i said are
called miners they are the participants
in the network who have the necessary
hardware and computing power to do all
the transactions to validate the
transactions and validate it they are
called as miners now in order to
understand bitcoin mining we need to
understand three major concepts of
blockchain it is based on distributed
public ledger it uses sha-256 encryption
algorithm and proof of work is the
underlying consensus algorithm for
bitcoin mining so distributed public
ledger a distributed ledger is a record
of all transactions maintained in the
blockchain network across the globe in
the network the validations of
transaction is done by bitcoin users
called as miners sha-256
now blockchain prevents unauthorized
access by using a hash function called
sha-256 to ensure that the blocks are
kept secure they are digitally signed
their hash value once generated cannot
be altered now seq 256 it takes an input
string of any size and returns a fixed
length 256 bit output value and that is
the primary feature of shf 256
encryption algorithm you give any input
it will always give you a 256-bit output
and it is a one-way function you cannot
derive the input reversally from the
output what you have generated and third
is the proof of work in blockchain
mining is a process to validate
transactions by solving a difficult
mathematical puzzle called proof of work
now in order to do that the primary
objective of the minor is to determine
the nonce value and that nonce value is
that mathematical puzzle that miner is
required to solve in order to generate a
hash which is less than the target
defined by the network for a particular
block now in the bitcoin network users
trying to solve mathematical puzzle are
called as minus now the puzzle is solved
by varying a nonce which produces a hash
value lower than a predefined condition
which is called as the target miners
verify the transactions and add the
block to the blockchain when confirmed
and verified as of today the miners who
solve the puzzle gets a reward of 12.5
bitcoins now once a block is added to
the blockchain the bitcoins associate
with the transactions can be spent so
once the block is validated then the
transfer of bitcoins associated with the
transactions aggregated in the block the
transfers are made then from one account
to the another now in order to generate
the hash let's see you use the sha-256
hashing algorithm you define the hash
value if it is less than the defined
condition the target then the puzzle is
deemed to be solved and if not then you
keep on incrementing nonce value and you
repeat the sha-256 hashing function
passing on to the nonce value and you
define generate the hash value again and
you keep doing this process till the
time you get the hash value which is
less than the target now let's take an
example so for example beyonce wants to
share 10 bitcoin with jennifer now in
order to do that what will be the steps
so beyond transaction data is shared
with bitcoin users the miners from the
memory code the transaction goes and
sits in a memory pool of unmined
transactions so in a memory pool set of
unmined or unconfirmed transactions wait
until they are verified and included in
a new block they remain in that
unconfirmed transaction pool now miners
competing to validate the transaction
using proof of work they keep on
continuously pulling the unconfirmed
transaction pool they pick up those
transactions and start validating those
transactions they aggregate in a data
block and start validating they start
solving the puzzle the miner who solves
the puzzle first shares his result
across the other nodes the other set of
miners now once the block has been
verified the nonce has been generated
then the nodes will start granting their
approval if maximum nodes grant their
approval the block becomes valid and is
added to the blockchain now
simultaneously the miner who has solved
the puzzle will also receive the reward
in the meanwhile which will be of 12.5
bitcoin which as of today stands at 98k
around dollars now the bitcoins the 10
btc for which the transaction was
initiated now will get triggered and
will get transferred from beyond to
jennifer now let's take a look at
certain facts in proof of work a
predefined condition the target is
adjusted for every 2016 block which is
approximately every 14 days and an
average time to mine a block is 10
minutes so basically the target keeps
automatically adjusting itself to keep
the block generation within the 10
minute time frame so this is the
representation so in order to keep the
time frame for block generation within
10 minutes the target keeps on adjusting
itself now the difficulty of the puzzle
changes the target changes depending on
the time it takes to mine a block so
this is how a difficulty of a block is
being generated it is the hash target of
the first block divided by the hash
target of the current block so this is
the difficulty which is being changed
after every 2016 blocks so basically it
is very hard to generate the proof of
work but it is very easy to verify by
the miners so once you have solved the
puzzle and you have broadcasted that yes
you have earned you have validated a
record you have determined the puzzle
for other miners it is very easy to
verify what you have done and once they
give their consensus the majority then
the block gets validated and gets added
to the blockchain now since the
difficulty depends on the hash target
its value keep on changing after every
2016 block as i said and as you can see
in due course from the day of inception
of bitcoin in 2009 till today difficulty
has increased exponentially and it has
been increasing and thereby the entire
effort of mining and the computing power
is also increasing so as of what was the
resources which were required to do
mining in 2009 you require more hashing
power more computing power in order to
do the mining today now what if someone
tries to hack the data so let's see
blockchain is a chain of blocks abc now
each block has solved a puzzle and
generated a hash value of its own which
is its identifier now suppose a person
tries to tamper a block block b and
tries to change the data which is
aggregated in the block so if the data
of the block will change the hash value
which is the digital signature of the
block will also change thereby it will
corrupt the chain which is subsequent to
it basically the blocks ahead of block b
will all get dealing because the
previous hash value of block c will not
remain valid so in order for the hacker
to make the entire blockchain valid for
the block b which he has changed he has
to change the hash value of all the
blocks ahead of block b which will
require huge huge amount of computing
power which will be next to impossible
so as you see the results in the
following block being invalid so with
this whole thing the blockchain is
making sure that the entire sequence
remains non-hackable and prevent data
modification now let's see what are the
underlying hardware requirements for
bitcoin mining and how the hardware has
evolved so in the early days miners used
to solve the puzzles using regular
processors the controlling processor
unit cpus now but it used to take a lot
of time for mining though the difficulty
levels were low but still it used to
take a lot of time now as i said the
difficulties never keep on changing and
growing so the miners also had to
increase the processing power so this
discovered that graphical processing
units gpus proved to be more efficient
than regular cpus so but this also had a
drawback of consumption of electricity
so any miner who has to calculate the
return on investment on the hardware he
also has to accommodate the cost of
electricity and other resources which
are going in in order to do the mining
so finally as of today they are using a
hardware called asic application
specific integrated circuit which was
specifically introduced for mining which
consumes less power and has a higher
computing power and a better hardware
for mining so miners are profitable when
their cost of resources to mine one
block is less than the price of the
reward they receive so definitely they
have to have the investment less than
the reward what they own so as of today
in blockchain miners use their resources
to verify a transaction they each time a
block is mined new bitcoins are created
in the network so the bitcoin total
supply is limited it is at 21 million
dollars approximately 21 million bitcoin
are in supply 17 to 18 million bitcoins
have already been mined so only three to
four million are left as of today a
reward of 12.5 bitcoin is given to the
miner on doing the transaction
verification but the bitcoin mining
reward goes by the huffing principle the
reward given to a miner is half every
210 000 blocks which is approximately
every four years so then after that
threshold is reached the bitcoin reward
will go down to 6.25 bitcoins so let's
take an example of a lottery ticket
where your chances of winning is
difficult so we are talking about what
is bitcoin mining pool your chances of
winning the lottery is difficult but in
a community if individuals buy multiple
lottery tickets and pool their tickets
together then this will increase their
probability and chances of winning more
so suppose you won the lottery then
based on the contribution the reward is
distributed among all the participants
bitcoin mining pool is a similar thing
it's a process where multiple nodes
share their resources together to mine a
block now when a block is solved the
miners split the reward equally based on
the amount of processing power they have
invested so it takes the pool members to
generate a final hash value then it
checks how much amount of work was
contributed by each pool member and as a
result the bitcoin reward gets
distributed proportionally amongst the
participants now let's take a look at a
demo on how can you see what is the
bitcoin reward now this is a actual
block of the bitcoin network as you can
see this is a block and
this is the block reward 12.5 bitcoin so
this was a block which was mined
this is the block number and
these are the set of transactions which
were part of this block now once this
block was mined by the miner all these
transactions then be done these are the
transfers of bitcoin from one account to
the other this is the nonce which was
generated by the miner or the mining
pool in order to mine the block and
these are the other attributes
and if you take a look at this url this
is an example of a mining pool it's a
demo account where the participants have
shared their mining resources and they
are mining it in a pool and see this is
the reward for which they are mining
this is the unconfirmed reward this is
the confirmed reward this is what they
have already validated and this is what
they have earned so far and let's see
what's in store for us today so what's
in it for you today we're gonna
understand why do we need blockchain
wallet what is a blockchain wallet how
do these wallet work what are the
different types of blockchain wallets
there are comparisons and a demo on the
usage of these blockchain wallets and we
will try to do certain transactions
using these wallets now before these
blockchain wallets came into existence
what were the means in order for us to
do the transactions and what were the
drawbacks in the old days the
transactions with whatever medium and
channels we had the problems were that
the transactions were slow and banks
were the central point of failure
basically any transaction which has to
go through has to go through some
intermediary channels and has to pass
through certain intermediaries like bank
which makes them a single point of
failure also there are issues in keeping
track of all accounts and balances data
get jeopardized manipulated or even get
corrupted across multiple systems where
the accounts and balances are maintained
now here comes into existence what is
called as blockchain wallet now what is
blockchain wallet a blockchain wallet is
a cryptocurrency wallet that allows
users to manage different kind of
cryptocurrencies for example bitcoin
ethereum etc now a blockchain wallet
helps exchanging of funds easily
transactions are secure as they are
cryptographically signed the wallet is
accessible from web or mobile devices
and the privacy and identity of the user
is maintained so therefore a blockchain
wallet provides all the features which
are necessary for a safe and secure
transfer and exchange of funds between
different parties a blockchain wallet is
a typical cryptocurrency wallet that
allows users to manage cryptocurrencies
it is very similar to the process of
sending or receiving money through
paypal or any other gateway which you
use today but now you can use
cryptocurrency instead similar to paypal
which you're using for making
transactions with your fiat currency now
let's take a look at the ecosystem of
blockchain wallets here are certain
examples like electrum blockchain.info
jaxx mycelium samurai and bitcoin paper
wallet these are just to name a few
blockchain wallets which are existing in
the market but there are many more based
on the requirement you have based on the
security you require and based on the
kind of wallet which suffices your need
so we will see what are the
categorizations of these kind of wallets
are now how do blockchain wallets work
let's take a look so before we move on
to how blockchain wallets work let's
understand what a private and a public
key is and how are these keys related to
a blockchain wallet now whenever you
create a blockchain wallet you are also
provided a private and a public key
which is associated with your wallet now
let's check an example in order to
understand this imagine a person knowing
your email address is sending you an
email so in our regular day to day
activity if we want to receive an email
from someone we give him or her our
email id and expect an email from them
now what if an unknown person is able to
send emails through my account so i am
giving my email address for receiving
email but when i am disclosing my email
id i am not assuming that someone will
be able to send emails through my
account because then for that he has to
be aware of my email account password so
knowing your email address will not give
a person the ability to send an email
from your account you are not giving
your password to the person to send an
email you're just giving the email
address to send an email from a
particular email address an individual
has to be aware of the password
associated with it now blockchain wallet
follows a similar process using public
key and private key both together public
key is similar to your email address so
basically whenever your wallet is
generated a public key is generated you
can share that public key with anyone in
order to receive funds private key is
top secret it's similar to your password
it should not get hacked or you should
not disclose it to anyone and you use
this private key to spend your funds so
now instead of sending an email imagine
you want to transfer money to your
friend this transfer process is done
through your blockchain wallet with
blockchain wallets you can now send and
receive cryptocurrencies so as i said a
blockchain wallet has two keys a public
key and a private key public key is
shared with everyone just like an email
address private key is just like your
password which should be kept secret
with the sender so with blockchain
wallet no one will be able to send
crypto coins just like emails through
your public key until they know your
private key but if someone gets access
to your private key there is a high
possibility that your account is hacked
and you might end up losing all the
cryptocurrency deposits in your account
now let's take a look what are the
typical features of a blockchain wallet
it's easy to use it's just like any
other software or a wallet which you use
for your day-to-day transactions it is
highly secure it is just a matter of you
securing your private key and it allows
instant transactions across geographies
barrier free without intermediaries and
also these transactions charges you low
cost fee and these wallets help you do
transactions across multiple
cryptocurrencies so you can make
payments across cryptocurrencies so
which helps you do easy currency
conversions now let's talk about what
are the different type of blockchain
wallets now basically there are two
types of blockchain wallets based on the
private keys one is hot wallet and
another is the cold wallet hot wallets
are like normal wallets which we carry
for day-to-day transactions and these
wallets are user-friendly cold wallets
cold wallets are similar to a vault
where cryptocurrencies are stored with a
high level of security now let's take a
look at the differences hot wallets are
online wallets through which
cryptocurrencies can be transferred
quickly they are available online on
internet example coinbase
blockchain.info cold wallets they are
digital offline wallets where the
transactions are signed offline and then
later disclosed online so they are not
maintained on the cloud on the internet
they are maintained offline to have high
security and the examples of cold wallet
are trezor and ledger now in case of hot
wallets private keys are stored in the
cloud for faster transfer in case of
cold wallets private keys are stored in
a separate hardware which are
disconnected from the internet or the
cloud or are stored in a paper based
document hot wallet they are easy to
access available online 24 7. it can be
accessed through desktop or mobile but
has a risk of unrecoverable theft when
hacked cold wallets this method of
transaction helps in protecting the
wallet from unauthorized access from
hacking and other online vulnerabilities
now the wallet can be further
distinguished on these criterias there
can be software wallets they can be
hardware wallets which are like kind of
usb driven and you plug into your usb
drive and your hardware wallet can be
used or they are a typical paper based
wallet where you print your public key
and a private key on a paper and keep it
in a secure place let's talk about
software wallet a software wallet is an
application that is downloaded on a
device either it could be a desktop or a
mobile or it could be a web-based wallet
which can be accessed online now here
are certain examples dax bread wallet
and copay are the popular software
wallets so software wallet can be
further categorized into desktop wallet
online or we can call it web wallets or
mobile wallets now desktop wallets are
like cold wallets in which the private
keys are stored in cold servers
basically the desktop wallets the
private keys are stored in your desktop
you can unplug it from the internet do
some offline transactions and then bring
it back online now in case the main
server is lost then a cold server
basically your desktop is used as a
backup server these wallets can be
downloaded on any computer but can only
be accessed from the system they are
installed on so you make sure the
desktop or the machine on which you i
have downloaded the desktop wallet is
safe has a backup you're maintaining the
hardware you're not letting the machine
go anywhere and it is on a secure
location now these wallets are
definitely cost efficient and one of the
examples is electrum and is one of the
most popular desktop wallet online
wallets are the other kind of hot
wallets that run on the cloud that are
available on the internet now here users
have the benefit of accessing these
wallets across any device it could be
tablet desktop or you can use it from
your mobile browser the private keys are
stored online and are managed by a third
party you have to be dependent on a
third party service now for example
green address is a bitcoin wallet which
is available on the web has an android
app is available on a desktop and also
is available on ios apple mobile wallets
mobile wallets are like similar to
online wallets except that they are
built only for mobile phone usage and
accessibility these wallets are also
user friendly and they have a user
friendly interface for which helps you
in doing transactions easily the example
is mycelium which is the best available
mobile wallet hardware wallet hardware
wallet is a type of cold storage device
typically like a usb which stores the
user's private key in a protected
hardware device
these wallets are similar to portable
devices that can be connected to the
computer can be plugged in as i said
earlier it is less prone to malware
attacks malicious attacks and it is hack
proof examples are nano ledger trezor
and kiki are the top hardware wallets
available in the market to make a
transaction from your hardware wallet
you have to ensure the hardware wallet
is plugged into your computer system
before you can do a transaction from
your hardware wallet paper wallet a
paper wallet is an offline process for
storing cryptocurrencies this wallet is
a printed paper consisting of both your
private key and a public key which are
accessed using a qr code now since these
wallets are safe they are widely used
for storing large amount of
cryptocurrencies now for example our
bitcoin paper wallet and my ether wallet
are one of the widely used paper wallets
but the question arises how do i add
cryptocurrency in my paper wallet in
order to make a transaction with your
paper wallet paper wallet works with
your software wallets the online wallets
to transfer funds from your software
wallet to the public address shown on
your paper wallet so basically first you
park your funds in a software wallet
then you transfer the funds from your
software wallet to the public address
printed on your paper wallet now let's
do the comparison blocked in info
blockchain info is a cryptocurrency
wallet which supports bitcoin and
ethereum it is easy to use and has a low
transaction fee it has its apis exposed
you can easily use them to order to make
your own custom wallets also ledger nano
ledger nano is a hardware wallet which
offers a high security to your account
it is available for bitcoin ethereum and
litecoin users it is also possible to
maintain multiple accounts and access
them anytime bitcoin paper wallet paper
wallet helps you to print your own
tamper resistant bitcoin wallet it
minimizes the threat of hacking jacks
jax is a software wallet which enables a
user to exchange currencies within the
wallet it is available for bitcoin
ethereum litecoin and many other
cryptocurrencies with jax a user can
view his updated balance as soon as the
processing is complete now let's take a
look at certain demos for the different
kind of wallets we have talked about so
let's first take an example of paper
wallet so bit address dot org provides
you a paper wallet it uses the client
side javascript in order to generate a
random hash for your wallet so you keep
moving your mouse and it will generate a
hash public and private key it is
recommended that when you are doing this
process you should be disconnected from
the internet and once these keys are
generated you can print it and keep it
secure and clear the cache of your
browser so as you can see on the screen
this is my public key for receiving my
bitcoins and this is the private key for
me to spend it i can print it and keep
it handy with me but of course the
safety of these physical documents
cannot be entirely guaranteed if a
hacker discovers the location of your
paper wallet and physically steals it
then they can access your bitcoin
holdings so basically it is of high
importance that you keep the paper
wallet in a very very secure location
some users hide or disguise the paper
wallet it should be protected from
physical damage if the keys fade or can
no longer be scanned then the user will
never again be able to access the
bitcoin which are parked in that address
also take care if you are using an
incorrect type of printer that also may
damage the paper wallet
now let's take a look for our second
example of online wallet here we are
taking an example of bitpay so you can
download bitpay online and create your
account over here
you can create a personal wallet you can
create a shared wallet or a joint share
wallet once you create a wallet like if
you see the example over here this is my
personal wallet and i have 3.645
test bitcoins over here
now in order to receive test bitcoins in
my account you can receive these test
bitcoins from testnet dot coin faucet
dot eu's hyphen in
now in order to receive it you just need
to
copy
your bitcoin address in the testnet
address
so the test net has given me 0.87
bitcoin so now my balance has increased
from 3.5 to 3.64 and i can see this
transaction
see three minutes ago i just received
0.872287 bitcoin the transaction is
still in process but in a while as this
transaction is getting mined on the test
net i will receive it now as i have
received it i can even make a
transaction and send it to someone
so from my personal account i can send
bitcoin to
someone whose bitcoin address i have and
i have to just paste it over here
transfer to bitcoin wallet either i can
select one of my own wallets or i can
search for any other bitcoin address
which someone has shared with me and i
can send it to that particular address
now let's take an example of our
hardware wallet how does hardware wallet
works with the online wallets so here we
have metamask which has a feature of
connecting with hardware wallet so once
you have metamask installed you will see
this option of connect hardware wallet
now metamask has provided support for
trezor so now once you connect your
hardware wallet the usb with your
computer
you can select an account you want to
view on that particular hardware wallet
and you can only choose one at a time
and then you can start using that
particular wallet for your decentralized
apps so basically once you have your
hardware connected it is integrated with
your meta mask and then you can start
running your decentralized apps so that
they can start using the tokens or the
currency in the particular hardware
wallet so use your hardware account like
you would with any ethereum account log
into dapps and send ethereums buy and
store erc20 tokens and non-fungible
tokens like cryptokitties so if you
click connect to trezor over here
metamask will start looking out for the
connected treasure device thank you for
a fascinating session saurabh now let us
learn how blockchain and ethereum are
different from one another after which
we will tell you 10 things you probably
didn't know about bitcoin some
applications of blockchain and how you
can become a blockchain developer and
today we're going to talk about bitcoin
versus ethereum now before we get into
it let's see what the nobel prize winner
in economics milton friedman had to say
in 1999 he believed that the internet
was going to be one of the major forces
in reducing the role of the government
he also believed that the one thing that
was missing was reliable electronic cash
and just like he predicted in 2009 the
cryptocurrency bitcoin was born so what
exactly is a cryptocurrency
a cryptocurrency works very similar to
how our normal currency works now normal
currency could be dollar euro pound yen
rupees and so on now any form of
currency that isn't a cryptocurrency
falls under the banner of normal
currency the normal currency is also
known as fiat currency now the major
difference between cryptocurrencies and
fiat currencies is that cryptocurrencies
are decentralized what does that mean
this means that cryptocurrencies don't
have a central authority controlling
them now for example they don't have a
bank or a government that regulate how
the cryptocurrency works in a way the
cryptocurrency works in a very
democratic fashion any change that needs
to take place is done only after a
majority of the people using the
cryptocurrency agree to it
cryptocurrencies and fiat currencies are
similar because both them were created
as a medium of exchange however that's
where the similarity ends with
cryptocurrencies there are no third
parties involved for example with fiat
currencies you have banks your money
lenders governments and so on with
cryptocurrencies we have cryptographic
functions to ensure that the
transactions are kept secure bitcoin
uses the sha-256 algorithm to ensure
that the transactions are kept secure
but most importantly cryptocurrencies
use blockchain
now a blockchain is a set of records
that are placed into a container known
as a block now these transactions are
kept public and in a chronological order
so what is bitcoin bitcoin which was
released in 2009 by the still unknown
satoshi nakamoto is a cryptocurrency
that's decentralized which means that
there's no central authority that
controls how it works it works using
encryption techniques like the sha-256
algorithm to help people send and
receive money across the world now as i
mentioned before the payments are
secured using cryptography the most
important point about bitcoin is that it
helps keep the identity of the people
sending and receiving money anonymous
the transaction fee is also very low now
we all know that when we perform a
transaction with the bank some amount of
money or service charge is levied on us
however with bitcoin this value is very
very low so what is ether or ethereum
ethereum which was created in 2015 by
vitalik buterin is a cryptocurrency
which provides ether tokens this is
equivalent to bitcoins that you find in
the bitcoin network ether is used by
users to build and deploy decentralized
applications now these are applications
whose back-end code is placed in a
distributed peer-to-peer network now
this is different from a regular
application as the backend code is
placed in a centralized server in this
case ether is also used to pay for
services like the computational power
that is required before a block can be
added to the blockchain and as
transaction fees ether also works very
similar to how bitcoin works and can be
used for peer-to-peer payments ether can
also be used to create smart contracts
now smart contracts work in such a way
that when a certain set of predefined
rules are satisfied a particular output
takes place if you're interested in
learning more about smart contracts i
suggest you click on the top right
corner and watch our what is a smart
contract video and now for the thing
you've been waiting for bitcoin versus
ethereum now on one side we have bitcoin
now bitcoin has proven itself to be a
very popular and well-known
cryptocurrency among everyone in the
world it also has the highest market cap
among all the cryptocurrencies available
right now in a way it's the current
world champion when it comes to
cryptocurrencies on the other side we
have the underdog ethereum now ethereum
did not have the revolutionary effect
that bitcoin did but it learned from
bitcoin and produced more
functionalities on the concepts of
bitcoin it is the second most valuable
cryptocurrency in the market right now
so in a way this is the fight between
the underdog and the world champion who
do you think will win now let's
understand how bitcoin and ethereum are
different from each other bitcoin was
the first cryptocurrency to be ever
created it was released in 2009 by a
group of people or a person known as
satoshi nakamoto no one really knows if
this person is alive or dead however
with this technology came the concept of
blockchain which is still
revolutionizing institutions around the
world on the other side ethereum was
released in 2015 by a researcher and a
programmer named vitalik buterin now
vitalik used the concepts of blockchain
and bitcoin and improved upon it
providing a lot more functionality
creating the ethereum platform for
distributed applications and smart
contracts bitcoin enables peer-to-peer
transactions bitcoin in this case acts
as a replacement for fiat currencies
just that it removes all the problems
associated with fiat currencies for
starters you don't have to pay high
transaction fees for a transaction at
the same time you also don't have a
centralized authority that regulates how
bitcoins work on the other hand we have
ethereum which enables peer-to-peer
transactions and also provides a
platform for creating and building smart
contracts and distributed applications a
smart contract allows users to exchange
just about anything of value be it
shares money real estate and so on
in bitcoin miners are able to validate
transactions with a method known as
proof of work this is the same with
ethereum as well proof of work involves
miners around the world trying to solve
a complicated mathematical puzzle to be
the first one to add a block to the
blockchain ethereum however will be
moving to something known as
proof-of-stake the concept of
proof-of-stake works in such a way that
a person can mine or validate
transactions in a block based on how
many coins he or she owns the more the
amount of coins that a person owns the
larger their mining power will be in the
case of bitcoin every time a miner adds
a block to the blockchain they're
rewarded with 12.5 bitcoins this reward
that they receive is expected to have
every 210 000 blocks now the next time
the reward is going to have is in the
year 2020 where the reward will reduce
from 12.5 bitcoins to 6.25 bitcoins per
block in the case of ethereum a miner or
a validator receives a value of three
ether every time a block is added to the
blockchain the transaction fees in
bitcoin is completely optional you can
pay the miner more amounts of money to
have them give special attention to your
transaction however as i mentioned
before the transaction will go through
even if you don't provide any money on
the other hand it is absolutely
necessary that you provide some amount
of ether for your transaction to be
successful the ether that you provide
will get converted into a unit called
gas now this gas drives the computation
that allows your transaction to be added
to the blockchain now let's talk about
the average amount of time it takes to
add a block to the blockchain in the
case of bitcoin it takes 10 minutes to
case of ethereum it takes only about 12
to 15 seconds for the same process now
let's talk about hashing algorithms or
how these systems can maintain their
privacy and ensure security bitcoin uses
a hashing algorithm known as sha-256
ethereum uses a cryptographic algorithm
called et hash now let's talk about some
important values associated with bitcoin
and ethereum the total number of coins
that each of them have are 17 million
bitcoins and 101 million ether now you
can see that ethereum has easily crossed
the 100 million mark however the market
capitalization for bitcoins is 110
billion us dollars whereas for ethereum
it's only 28 billion so even though
ethereum has a larger number of coins in
the market does not reach up to the
level of bitcoin the number of
transactions that take place in a day
for bitcoin is 219 000 and at the same
time for ethereum it's 659 000. now you
can see this throughout july where the
number of transactions per day stay more
or less the same for bitcoin and
ethereum now the number of blocks that
are created for bitcoin is 537 000 for
ethereum that grows up to 6 billion now
this has more to do with the fact that
the amount of time it takes for a block
to be added to ethereum is much less as
compared to bitcoin now the block size
for bitcoin is 628.286
kilobytes and 25.134 kilobytes for
ethereum now you can see that the market
value of bitcoin is significantly higher
than any form of digital currency in the
market right now it is however closely
followed by ether which hopes to take
over one day and now for the big
question which one is better the answer
depends entirely on your requirements
bitcoin works better as a peer-to-peer
transaction system and ethereum works
well when you need to create and build
distributed applications and smart
contracts at the end of the day the
choice is entirely up to you 5
industries that blockchain will disrupt
let's start with banking suppose you're
in san francisco and you want to send
money to your friend now for this
transfer to take place you need the help
of a central authority in this case it's
the bank now say you're sending them a
hundred dollars now out of this hundred
dollars ten dollars goes as transaction
fee to the bank the rest goes to your
friend which is ninety dollars now this
transaction fee at times can be
expensive the process of transferring
money can also be time consuming the act
of sending money overseas is also a lot
more complicated due to the exchange
rates and other hidden fees now
blockchain is disrupting the system by
providing a peer-to-peer payment system
now this provides high security and
doesn't cost as much this system
eliminates the need of a central
authority now blockchain provides fast
cheap and borderless payments across the
world you can perform transfers to any
part of the world now cryptocurrencies
like bitcoin eliminates the need for a
third party in this case a bank to make
transactions now blockchain records all
the transactions in a decentralized
ledger this ledger is accessible by any
of the bitcoin users for example let's
talk about a cryptocurrency application
caller this provides peer-to-peer money
transfers now this application allows
users to store transfer and receive
digital money which can be stored in
their mobile phones or pcs the recipient
can withdraw this cash via anabra teller
the most important thing here is that
users don't need to have a bank account
to use this service next up we have
cyber security now imagine you're in
office one day and you find out that
your data has been modified the previous
evening someone went through your data
and altered it now cyber attacks are a
huge cause of concern among the public
it can have huge repercussions to a
person's life so it's essential that we
find an effective solution against
people going through our data
unauthorized and tampering it that's
where blockchain comes in blockchain
with its decentralized system makes it
suitable for environments where there's
a lot of security required all the
information that's stored inside the
bitcoin networks are verified and
encrypted using a cryptographic
algorithm now this ensures that there's
no single point of entrance for a wide
scale attack now with blockchain it's
also easy to identify malicious attacks
due to the peer-to-peer connections
where data cannot be ordered or tampered
by ensuring that there's no central
authority blockchain provides a
transparent and secure way of recording
transactions this is at the same time
ensuring that none of your private
information is disclosed to anyone for
example let me tell you about a company
called guard time that secures his data
using blockchain technology now
guardtime uses a completely unorthodox
method as opposed to a centralized
system this company uses blockchain
technology it distributes the data among
the nodes of its users now let's talk
about supply chain management say you
ordered for some food from online you
get the delivery for the food you get
the food delivered to you and you find
out that the food has surprisingly low
quality now with blockchain technology
you can trace the supply chain back to
its beginning to find out where things
went wrong for example you can find out
where the farm is where the product is
grown how the production was whether
something went wrong with the
distributor whether something went wrong
with the retailer or something went
wrong at your hand now in supply chain
management blockchain provides permanent
transparency and validation of
transaction shared by multiple supply
chain partners that means you can
validate each and every step of the
supply chain all the blockchain entries
are permanent and transparent this makes
it easier for the customer to view the
transaction history of the product they
just purchased in a blockchain
transactions are recorded in a
decentralized distributed ledger each
transaction is recorded into a block and
anyone can verify the authenticity or
status of a product being delivered now
it can also be used for seafood
verification here we can track the
seafood from ocean to the market now
take the example of the pacific tuna
project now you have three blocks here
each one containing fishing details
exported import details and purchasing
details the blockchain supply chain
management provides a step-by-step
verification to track the tuna fish in
the process this prevents illegal
phishing next up we have healthcare say
you're in a hospital and you're asking
for reports for a medical test you did
yesterday the receptionist tells you to
wait and even after 4 hours you still
don't get your report apart from this
annoying delay have you realized that
any person who has access to the system
can corrupt the data apart from this
annoying delay have you realized that
any person who has access to the system
can corrupt the data since information
is stored in the physical memory of a
system blockchain eliminates a central
authority and ensures that you have
rapid access to data here each block is
connected to another block and the data
is distributed across the nodes this
makes it difficult for a hacker to
corrupt the data another major problem
in healthcare is counterfeit medication
the main issue is that counterfeit
medicines are difficult to distinguish
from real medicines the solution comes
in the form of blockchain with the help
of supply chain management here the
medicine's provenance can be traced for
example united healthcare has improved
its privacy security and
interoperability of medical records
using blockchain now time for some
honorable mentions the insurance
industry with blockchain's decentralized
system insurance companies can easily
identify false claims and prevent
forgeries transportation utilizing
blockchain enables traceability in the
transportation industry where the
shipment of goods can be easily tracked
now let me tell you about cloud storage
with an example storage is a
decentralized cloud storage by
eliminating servers and utilizing
blockchain it can securely store its
data in the cloud with high speed and
low cost users can earn money by sharing
their extra hard drive space on the
storage network real estate deploying
blockchain technology in real estate
increases the speed of the conveyance
process and eliminates the necessity for
money exchanges let's talk about the
government in a traditional voting
process electoral fraud is an illegal
activity that takes place almost always
now most citizens who want to vote must
wait in a queue and cast their word to a
local authority this can be very time
consuming process why not bring this
process online online voting systems
fail due to the lack of security
blockchain can be used to solve these
issues it can be used for counting votes
and verifying voters using blockchain
voters can submit their votes without
revealing their identity in public
officials can count the words with
absolute accuracy knowing that each id
has only one vote associated with it
fake quotes cannot be created as data
dampering is closely impossible with
blockchain once your vote is added to
the ledger the information can never be
erased now let me tell you an example of
me vote now miwot is a token based
blockchain platform which is very
similar to a digital ballot box now with
me mode people are able to go through a
smartphone so voters cast their vote
after the verification the word gets
recorded in the blockchain the voter
identities are secured and the results
are not modified but blockchain is also
useful in some other things for digital
asset registries with blockchain fast
and secure registration of any asset is
possible it can be used with the notary
utilizing blockchains technology with
the notary seal can be a really fast way
to prove a document's authenticity with
tax deploying blockchain can result in
quicker tax payments lower rates of tax
evasion and lesser efforts in tax
auditing blockchain can increase
security and transparency in
governmental systems by 2020 dubai hopes
to become 100 blockchain government by
making all of its government services
available on the blockchain technology
10 things you didn't know about bitcoin
firstly we have the mysterious creator
now in 2009 a person or a group of
people known as satoshi nakamoto
introduced bitcoin to the world he
vanished off the internet in late 2010
he hasn't been heard from since now just
like his identity is shorter than
mystery nobody really knows if he's even
alive or dead the only communication
people had with him were through emails
and forums his bitcoin wallet holds
around 980hz 000 bitcoins which makes
him one of the richest people on the
planet next up we have the satoshi now
as a sign of respect for the bitcoins
creator the smallest unit of a bitcoin
is known as a satoshi one satoshi is
valued at around 0.00
669 for us dollars which is a very very
low value now to make one bitcoin you
need approximately 100 million satoshi's
now according to the current bitcoin
values which fluctuates a lot to make a
dollar you'd need close to 15 800
satoshi's losing bitcoins losing your
bitcoin address which is also known as
your private key not only means losing
your unique identification it also means
you lose all the bitcoins in your wallet
research shows that at least 60 percent
of all bitcoin addresses are ghosts
which means a huge chunk of the
population that's using the bitcoin
network have lost their addresses now
these are the people who have lost their
addresses and have no way to access
their wallet liberland now in april 2015
a micro nation between croatia and
serbia known as liberland was born now
this was founded by virgilka a
politician publicist activist and the
president of liberland now the official
currency of liberland is bitcoin now the
government took this move believing that
bitcoin and its underlying concepts of
blockchain provides a secure and
transparent method for recording
electronic financial and physical assets
processing power the process of mining
bitcoins is a expensive process now you
pay a high toll to do this like your
money your time and electricity now
mining bitcoins require servers that are
used for that specific purpose alone now
the faster you process the data the
faster the block can be added to the
blockchain and the faster you're
rewarded with bitcoins power consumption
now just imagine how much electricity
ireland consumes in a year approximately
five thousand kilowatt hour now how much
do you think all the bitcoin mining
farms together consume 60 terawatt all
which is approximately 6 into 10 raised
to 10 kilowatt hours which is a large
amount of power now the entire country
of ireland which is the second most
populated city in europe and has 84 421
kilometer square of area consumes lesser
electricity than all these farms
combined bitcoin ban now although
several countries around the world like
canada and america have wholeheartedly
accepted bitcoin there are some that
haven't countries like bolivia iceland
bangladesh and ecuador have completely
banned the usage of bitcoins there are
also countries like india thailand and
iran who ask their residents to be
careful while using cryptocurrencies
they haven't completely banned it
however they do not accept it as a legal
tender low limited number there's a
limit to how many bitcoins can exist in
the market this number is capped at 21
million bitcoins as of this moment 17
million bitcoins are already in
circulation to give you an idea that's
almost 80 percent of the 21 million
already done but don't worry until 2140
we'll still have bitcoins to mine this
is because of how miners are rewarded
now miners are rewarded with 12.5
bitcoins for each block added to the
blockchain and every four years the
reward reduces by half the next halving
is supposed to occur in 2020 where the
reward reduces to 6.25 bitcoins the
power of b the terms bitcoin with an
uppercase b and bitcoin with the
lowercase b mean two different things
the only thing that differentiates the
two into two completely different things
is the letter b the lowercase b in
bitcoin refers to the cryptocurrency
that is used to perform the transactions
the uppercase b in bitcoin refers to the
ledger that stores information regarding
these transactions faster than
supercomputers the world's fastest
supercomputer the summit works at 122.3
petaflops which is nothing but a
quadrillion floating point operations
per second now if you take the bitcoin
network completely into consideration
the processing power is about 80 million
704 290 petaflops but the only thing
here is that a supercomputer can do
several different things but the only
thing the bitcoin network does is add
blocks to the blockchain and with that
we've reached the end of the video i
hope you guys enjoyed it and i've
learned something new about bitcoin if
you feel like we've missed out on
something interesting that you've come
across let us know in the comments below
and today we're going to do something
very interesting today we're going to go
through some of the applications of
blockchain now before we get into it let
me tell you what exactly is a blockchain
now a blockchain is a list of records or
blocks which stores data publicly and in
a chronological order now the data
within these blocks or records are
secured using cryptography they don't
have a central authority controlling
them anyone has access to the data
within this network but not everyone can
alter the data and everyone has copies
of this data so now that you know what
blockchain is let's get into this video
today we'll be talking about blockchain
when it's used in supply chain
management blockchain and cyber security
how blockchain is used for voting and
other applications of blockchain so now
let's have a look at supply chain
management now let's look at a scenario
before blockchain so there's a delivery
boy bringing john his order of apples
now john thanks him and sees that his
apples are rotten and john says that he
wants his money back however the
delivery boy says he can't help since
he's just the delivery boy not the
person who created the product so these
problems are the ones that were faced
before blockchain but with blockchain
technology there is traceability across
the supply chain this means that you can
trace back to what happened to the
product at each step of the supply chain
blockchain technology enables these
transactions to be tracked in a very
secure and transparent manner now some
benefits of using blockchain technology
other there's a single record policy
which means there's a single record
throughout the entire supply chain
there's reduced costs since there's no
requirement for multiple records across
the entire supply chain there's
eliminating error and less human
intervention now the last two points
come somewhat in correlation since the
less of the human intervention usually
the lesser the amount of error let's
have a look at an example of a supply
chain management so the product starts
from the farm goes through storage
undergoes food processing it's
manufactured distributed given to the
retailer and finally reaches the
customer now in supply chain management
blockchain is able to provide a
permanent record a whole lot of
transparency and the ability to validate
the transactions that are shared across
multiple supply chain partners with
blockchain the transactions are recorded
in a decentralized distributed ledger
now the advantage of this is that anyone
can verify the authenticity or the
status of a product that is being
delivered now if you want to look at a
real life example you have to look no
further than walmart walmart is building
a blockchain distributed ledger so that
they can connect and track poke
suppliers shippers purchases and other
units involved in its supply chain that
are delivering the food product across
china now this is done to reduce the
risk of data tampering or inaccuracy or
inaccuracy now let's have a look at how
blockchain helps cyber security imagine
the scenario where a is sending twenty
dollars to b a sends this money and this
transaction details are stored in the
cloud now what if a hacker hacks the
data within the cloud and tampers this
he tampers this in such a way that he
receives the 20 instead of b here you
can see the hacker being all smug about
it now this is the main problem with the
current banking system now it is prone
to cyber attacks because it has a
centralized network this can also lead
to fraud as well as data theft cyber
attacks are one of the biggest threats
that the public has to face however
blockchain is a solution that makes sure
that your data is protected from
tampering as well as helps improving
cyber security across a number of
different industries some of the
benefits are that it provides high
security with the help of the
cryptography that i mentioned before it
has a decentralized storage quick
transactions which take only about 10
minutes and lower cost as compared to
banking transaction costs now let's look
at the same scenario but with the help
of bitcoins or blockchain now a is
sending
0.0025 bitcoins to b which amounts to
approximately 20 dollars these bitcoins
are sent and blockchain which is a
distributed ledger distributes the data
across multiple nodes within the network
and secures this data using cryptography
another thing that you have to remember
is that each node has a copy of the
ledger and cryptography protects the
data within it against any changes
making it immutable now imagine a hacker
trying to hack the data here he's
unsuccessful because the peer-to-peer
connection which prevents data from
being altered as well as tampered now
and finally b receives the twenty
dollars in bitcoins now for a real life
application mastercard has its own
blockchain project where mastercard is
using blockchain for sending as well as
receiving money it also allows the
exchange of currency without the need of
a central authority now let's have a
look at how blockchain can help with the
voting process now before blockchain a
voter would have to submit their voter
id their water ids need to be verified
and after the verification the water
would submit his or her word to the evm
or the electronic voting machine after
that the voting is complete however it
is possible for the evm to be hacked
since it's a centralized system this can
lead to some amount of manipulation with
the word count however with the
decentralized system like blockchain it
is possible to completely eliminate any
scope of forgery as well as data
manipulation now let's have a look at
how voting can be performed with the
help of blockchain now first the water
downloads a voting application
the voter submits a voter id and
registers for the election after the
verification is complete the voter has
been authorized to cast his or her vote
and the water submits his or her word
without revealing their identity to the
public now once the support has been
added to the blockchain the information
within the blockchain can never be
erased after this the officials can
count these words knowing that each id
can be attributed to just one vote now
with blockchain voters can also count
the number of votes themselves using
blockchain in the voting process
provides complete transparency by
eliminating any need for third-party
systems to be involved along with that
it can also eliminate voter fraud as
well as election rigging it increases
the transparency in the voting process
and reduces the expense of conducting
the elections now in real life examples
meewort which is a token based
blockchain platform works very similar
to that of a digital ballot box now it
protects the integrity of the ward as
well as protects the security of the
election process now this is already
implemented in australia so it's only a
matter of time before this or similar
technologies can be set up across the
world now let's have a look at some of
the other applications there's insurance
where with blockchain they can eliminate
forgery as well as false claims and real
estate where this increases the speed of
the conveyance process and eliminates
any requirement for money exchanges so
if talking about blockchain and its
applications have caught your interest i
suggest we get on to simplylearn.com i'm
going to tell you how you can become a
blockchain developer now before we begin
let's see the current situation of the
market 84 percent of companies are now
dabbling into blockchain blockchain is
the fastest growing skill in the u.s
freelance job market apple st wozniak is
getting involved with blockchain
projects and jpmorgan cio believes that
blockchain will replace existing
technology as we can see with the amount
of focus organizations are putting on
blockchain and what tech influencers
around the world have to say about it we
can see clearly that they really believe
that blockchain can have a tremendous
positive impact on our lives and the
market as a whole so it's no surprise
that blockchain has worldwide acclaim
now it's created a huge number of job
opportunities across the world and one
such job is that of a blockchain
developer so here's what we're going to
learn today who is a blockchain
developer what are the types of
blockchain developers the steps you have
to follow to become a blockchain
developer the obstacles you might face
while learning blockchain the salaries
offered to blockchain developers and how
companies are using blockchain right now
so who is a blockchain developer a
blockchain developer is someone who
designs implements and supports a
blockchain network so in a way they are
responsible for setting up the
blockchain network and then ensuring
that it works properly they create and
optimize blockchain protocols for
example is the network a public network
they create such protocols and then
optimize it based on that usage or
requirement they develop distributed
applications and smart contracts on the
blockchain network now let's talk about
the different types of blockchain
developers so they fall under two major
categories core blockchain developers
and blockchain software developers a
core blockchain developer works on the
core features and the architecture of
the blockchain network basically they're
in charge of the entire blockchain
network they manage the architecture of
the network supervise the blockchain
network they work on consensus
algorithms for example there's the
proof-of-work algorithm in bitcoin and
set up blockchain protocols a core
blockchain developer works very much
like a core web developer now the main
thing is that they both work on course
concepts now just like blockchain
developers work on protocols you have
web developers working on protocols like
http or tcpip and so on now let's talk
about a blockchain software developer
now they work on blockchain to create
applications now they create smart
contracts develop distributed
applications and work on the front and
back end application development
blockchain software developers are also
very similar to web application
developers both of them create
applications on a network that's already
set up by core developers so how do you
become a blockchain developer so before
you start off on your path to becoming a
blockchain developer there are some
things that you really have to know now
we're going to talk about the
prerequisites first up you have
programming languages now it is
absolutely necessary that you be
well-versed in programming languages
before you can get onto blockchain
development most blockchains are created
in languages like java c plus plus
javascript go python c sharp and so on
so let me emphasize how important it is
that you know programming languages now
for core blockchain development any of
these aforementioned languages will do
the job for you however in case you have
to create distributed applications and
smart contracts on ethereum it is
mandatory that you learn the programming
language solidity then you need to
understand the fundamentals of object
oriented programming now the concepts of
object-oriented programming which anyone
who codes will know is the wrapping up
of data and functions into a single unit
this is exactly what blockchains
function on for example you have the
ethereum block here it has two
components data and function the user
details act as the data now this data
includes the person who's sending the
transaction or how much money they're
planning to transfer then you have the
function which is the command to send
and receive payments then you need to
learn about flat and relational
databases now blockchain was created on
the basis of these two types of
databases a flat database stores data in
a single table structure and a
relational database uses a number of
tables and can cross-reference records
across tables so it is necessary that
you understand how these two databases
work to completely understand how
blockchain was created from their
concepts then you need to learn what
data structures are you need to
understand the working of data
structures like stack linked list queue
and so on this is because blockchain by
itself is a backlinked list each block
in a blockchain references the previous
block now this is done by a field in the
blocks header known as the previous hash
that holds the hash value of the
preceding block knowledge about web
application development by being well
versed in web app development you're
opening yourself to a wide range of
opportunities to create web and mobile
applications using blockchain technology
because regardless of whether the
application works on blockchain
technology the front end can be created
only with web application development
then you need to know about networking
blockchains work on the internet so you
need to understand the many concepts
regarding networks for example how
systems are able to communicate with
each other how the network works and so
much more now after you're done with all
of this you're ready to start your
journey to become a blockchain developer
the first step is to understand the
concepts of blockchain now satoshi
nakamoto's white paper bitcoin appeared
to peer electronic cash system gives a
detailed account on how bitcoin works
and introduces us to the concept of
blockchain so if you want to learn
firsthand how blockchain works from the
creator of bitcoin himself i would
suggest you go to satoshi nakamoto's
paper
next you need to learn important terms
related to blockchain for example what
is a minor what is a block what is a
public distributed ledger hash
encryption proof of work mining and so
much more then you can learn how systems
other than bitcoin like ethereum
hyperledger hashgraph and so on use
blockchain to work with their technology
the second step involves understanding
the economics behind cryptocurrencies in
blockchain blockchain technologies work
on crypto economics which is nothing but
the combination of two words
cryptography and economics cryptography
in blockchain involves hashing digital
signatures and proof of work hashing is
involved in maintaining the privacy of a
user within the network this is made
possible with the help of cryptographic
algorithms for example in bitcoin we
have the sha-256 algorithm and eth in
ethereum digital signatures help
validate a particular user within the
network this is made possible with the
combination of the user's public and
private keys proof of work involves
miners around the world trying to solve
a complex mathematical puzzle to be able
to add a block to the blockchain on the
economic side you need to understand how
miners are incentivized the users who
add and take part in the blockchain are
given cryptocurrencies now people who
take decisions also have the right to
charge a fee for their service for
example if a person has a block and he
has to decide what transactions he's
going to add to that block he has the
right to charge you some amount of money
if you want your transaction to be added
to his block good users of the network
are rewarded with monetary compensation
or the ability to take decisions bad
users of the network have to pay a fine
or have their rights to take decisions
stripped away step three is to
understand how cryptocurrencies work
with cryptocurrencies there's a whole
number of steps before a process is
complete you need to understand how each
and every step works for example first
how a sender begins the transaction to
send money to the receiver how the
message is encrypted and transmitted
across the network how miners are able
to verify that transaction how the block
is added to the blockchain how money is
deducted from each of the participants
wallets you need to understand the
relationship between each and every step
of the process and how they interact
with each other step 4 getting some
hands-on experience now after you're
done with all the steps that i mentioned
before this one's the hardest practical
application so even if you know all the
theory if you don't have any practical
experience it won't have a very large
impact so you need to start coding and
creating your own smart contracts you
need to create your own distributed
applications on the ethereum platform
also let me remind you for you to be
able to create smart contracts or
distributed applications you need to
have learned the programming language
solidity and finally you can invest in
bitcoins or other cryptocurrencies so
that you can have an understanding of
how they actually work now it's very
important that you also keep yourself
updated regarding cryptocurrencies and
blockchains and bitcoins by reading up
on blogs and forums you can take part in
discard chat rooms you can use the
telegram application which has a very
active community on cryptocurrencies and
blockchain you can involve yourself in
subreddits like our slash blockchain our
slash bitcoin and other related
subreddits you can get on coin market
cap that talks about market
capitalizations of several
cryptocurrencies coin market cal and so
much more there's an abundance of
resources on the internet that you can
take advantage of now let's talk about
the obstacles that you might face while
learning blockchain now you've noticed
that blockchain isn't very easy there's
a lot of content to cover now to make
matters worse you could also face some
of these problems first of them is
outdated content now the tutorials and
content that you might find online
cannot possibly keep up with the
constantly changing technology so it's
only natural that the content that you
might get might be a little outdated
which isn't what you want you want the
latest and the most highest quality
content secondly lack of quality content
now there's an abundance of sources that
you can learn from and since there's
such a wide variety it's possible that
you might end up using a type of source
that's of low quality or of substandard
quality now let's talk about salaries
that you can get in a blockchain job now
in the united states blockchain
developers earn 130 000 per annum
according to burning glass technologies
in the more tech oriented areas of u.s
like silicon valley new york and boston
they earn up to 150 000 per annum
several companies around the world have
invested heavily into incorporating
blockchain into their processes now you
have companies like alphabet bank of
america wells fargo apple microsoft and
so on so this is a clear indication that
companies are very interested in hiring
people who are skilled enough in the
concepts of blockchain and finally how
are companies using blockchain walmart
uses blockchain to keep track of each
and every step in the supply chain with
this they are able to track down where
the problem area is and to ensure that
that problem is solved before it can
happen again you have jpmorgan chase and
co this company created their own
blockchain application called quorum
that solves the processing that allows
private transactions to take place in a
group of participants whose identities
are known the agricultural bank of china
created a learning system using
blockchain that aim to help small and
medium-sized agricultural businesses
that didn't have a good credit record
now how can simply learn help you
simply learn provides certification
courses that give you an introductory or
an advanced understanding into the
concepts of blockchain the introductory
blockchain basics course provides 12
hours of self-paced learning and covers
all the concepts related to bitcoin and
blockchain data structures moreover it
gives you an introduction into
blockchain bitcoin blockchain mining
buying and selling bitcoins emerging
trends in blockchain and so much more
now the advanced course or the
blockchain certification training course
provides 32 hours of instructor-led
training 50-plus hands-on exercises
using blockchain technology nine
practical projects covering ethereum
hyperledger and bitcoin case studies and
so on it also helps you understand
solidity programming ethereum coding
advanced smart contracts ethereum
application architecture real life
projects and so much more the content of
these courses are constantly updated to
keep up with emerging trends in the
market now saurabh will take you through
30 hand-picked questions you might face
in a blockchain interview so let's get
started and understand what kind of
interview questions can come for a
blockchain interview so let's start with
certain beginner level questions now
when you face a blockchain interview you
can get different variety of questions
so we will be covering that what kind of
questions can be asked at each level
intermediate and expert level so one of
the few questions which you could be
asked is what is the difference between
blockchain and hyperledger blockchain is
basically the underlying concept
blockchain is a decentralized technology
of immutable records called blocks which
are secured using cryptography whereas
hyperledger is a platform or an
organization that allows people to build
private blockchain so basically
blockchain is a concept is a technology
using blockchain you can build public
and private blockchains but hyperledger
is a specific technology which allows
you to build only private blockchains
now blockchain is divided into public
private and consortium blockchains
hyperledger is specifically a private
blockchain technology with access to
blockchain data is limited to predefined
users and it is defined
using certain configurations and
programming blockchain can be used in
multiple fields like business
governments healthcare other different
kind of domains and etc hyperledger is
primarily used in blockchain for
enterprise-based solutions so wherever
we are talking about public blockchain
is like usage of blockchain on internet
and hyper ledger based blockchain
solutions are solutions which are meant
for internet within an organization
within a corporation second how do you
explain blocked in technology to someone
who doesn't know it so basically in
simple terms blockchain technology is a
distributed ledger which stores
transaction details in the form of
immutable records non-modifiable records
which are called blocks which are
secured using cryptography so in order
to explain simplistically let's consider
an example of a school where blockchain
is similar to a digital report card of a
student now each block contains students
records which has a label stating the
date and time of when the record was
entered or when the record was
registered on the blockchain now neither
the teacher nor the student can modify
the details of the block cannot modify
the record of report cards therefore the
record becomes non-modifiable immutable
also the teacher owns a private key that
allows him or her to make new records
and the student owns a public key to
view and access the report card at any
time so basically the teacher owns the
right to update the record but the
student only owns the right to view the
record now this method makes the data
both active and secure and this is what
blockchain brings on the table these are
the primary attributes for which
blockchain is getting widely adopted to
have immutable records available for
view to the public and available for
updating in an untemperable way now what
is a merkle tree merkle tree is a data
structure which is used for verifying a
block it is in a form of a binary tree
containing cryptographic hashes of each
block so basically a merkle tree is
structured similar to a binary tree each
leaf node is a hash of a block of
transactional data so each leaf node is
basically a transaction which is hashed
and each non-leaf node is a hash of its
leaf node so basically hash a a is the
hash of two blocks a and hash b merkle
root or the hash root is the final hash
of all the transaction hashes so
basically merkel root is the hash of
hash a a and bb so it encompasses all
the transactions which are underlying
all the non-leaf nodes what do you mean
by blocks in the blockchain technology
what is the definition of a block so
blockchain is a distributed database of
immutable records called blocks which
are secured using cryptography now as
you see there are the certain attributes
of a block which are displayed here you
have previous hash transaction details
nonce and a target hash value a block is
like a record of transactions each time
a block is verified it gets recorded in
chronological order on the main
blockchain so as you can see as it is
represented over here every time a new
block is verified it gets added to the
main blockchain with all those
attributes populated now once the data
is recorded it cannot be modified it
cannot be changed now another question
which could come into your interview is
how is blockchain distributed ledger
different from a traditional ledger it
is a very important question we need to
know the basic difference and
justification if we have to move from a
traditional database to a blockchain
based distributed ledger what benefit it
bring on the table so certain
differences which are very visible are
transparency blockchain distributed
ledger is highly transparent as compared
to traditional database distributed
ledgers are irreversible once any
information is registered on a
distributed ledger cannot be modified
whereas on a traditional ledger it is
reversible basically distributed ledger
is more secure it uses cryptography
every transaction is hashed and recorded
in a traditional ledger the security can
be compromised in a distributed ledger
there is no central authority it's a
distributed system the participants of
the network holds the authority to
maintain the sanity of the network and
are responsible for validating the
transactions whereas traditional ledgers
are based on the concept of centralized
authority and control and all the
transactions are controlled by the
centralized authority in a distributed
ledger identities are unknown and are
hidden whereas in a traditional ledger
identities of all the participants have
to be known before the transaction can
happen in a distributed ledger there is
not a single point of failure as the
data is distributed information is
shared across multiple nodes even if a
single node fails the other nodes carry
the same copy of the information whereas
in a traditional ledger in a centralized
database ledger based system that
particular system becomes a single point
of failure if the single system crashes
the entire application or the entire
network comes to a standstill ability to
modify data no once the data or a
transaction is registered it cannot be
altered and a traditional ledger it is
possible how validation is done so in a
distributed ledger it is done by the
participants of the network in a
traditional ledger it is controlled by
the centralized authority copy of ledger
is shared amongst all the participants
of a distributed ledger each participant
consists the same information in the
ledger in a traditional ledger only a
single copy is maintained at a
centralized location it is not shared
amongst all the participants thereby
again it remains as a single point of
failure if you have any queries you can
put your comments in the comments
section of this video and we will
definitely come back to you how can you
identify a block what are the attributes
of a block in order to understand it so
every block consists of four fields it
holds the hash value of the previous
block therefore it gets linked in a
blockchain it contains the details of
the aggregated transactions which are
aggregated in the block it has a value
called non nonce is a random value which
is used to vary the value of the hash in
order to generate the hash value less
than the target and then finally you
have a hash of the block itself it is
the digital signature of this block a
unique hash for this block it is a
alphanumeric value which is used to
identify a block so that is the identity
of the block the hash address is the
unique identification of a block it is a
hex value of 64 characters that has both
letters and digit it is obtained by
using sha-256 algorithm now this is the
way it is structured the hash of the
previous block the transaction data and
the nouns consolidate the header of the
block they all together are passed
through a hashing function and then the
hash value the digital signature of the
block is then generated what is
cryptography and what is its role in
blockchain blockchain uses cryptography
primarily to secure users identities and
ensure the transactions are done safely
with the hash function so all the user
identities and the transaction on a
blockchain are encrypted cryptography
uses public and private keys to encrypt
and decrypt data so basically it uses
the public and private key
infrastructure in order to maintain the
encryption of the information on a
blockchain network in blockchain network
public key can be shared with all the
bitcoin users all the blockchain users
so public key is just like your address
which you can share it with anyone but a
private key is like your password it is
kept secret with the user so basically
blockchain uses cryptography to secure
user identities and ensure transactions
are done safely and how does it do it it
uses sha-256 algorithm which is secure
which provides a unique hash output for
every input and it is a very popular
algorithm the basic feature of sha-256
is that whatever input you pass it will
give you a standard output alphanumeric
output of 64 characters so basically it
is a one-way function you can derive an
encrypted value from the input but you
can't do vice versa now what are the
different types of blockchains which
exist there are three different types of
blockchains public blockchain private
blockchain and consortium blockchain
public blockchain ledgers are visible to
all the users on the internet and any
user can verify and add a block of
transactions to the blockchain basically
it's publicly available anyone can
participate in the network and get
hooked up so examples are bitcoin and
ethereum private blockchain ledgers are
visible to all the users on the internet
but only specific users in the
organization can verify an ad
transaction so it's a kind of a
permissioned blockchain though the
information can be available publicly
but the controllers and the validators
of the blockchain are within the
organizations and are pre-determined the
example is block stack consortium
blockchain here the consensus process is
controlled by only specific nodes
however ledgers are visible to all the
participants in the consortium
blockchain example is ripple now what
happens when you try to deploy a file
with multiple contracts in blockchain
deploying a file with multiple contracts
is not possible the compiler only
deploys the last contract from the
uploaded file and the remaining
contracts are neglected and this is the
way a smart contract is deployed on a
blockchain network now very interesting
question what is a genesis block it's a
very important question and could be
asked in an interview multiple times so
basically genesis block is the first
block in the blockchain which is also
known as block zero so as you can see
the sequence number of this block is
zero and in blockchain it is the only
block that does not refer to any
previous block so the hash value of the
previous block will be all zeros because
it is the first block also it defines
parameters of the blockchain such as
level of difficulty consensus mechanisms
etc to mine the block so basically it
defines the primary attributes of the
blockchain which is going to get
initiated from the genesis block onwards
now let's look at some of the questions
which would come if you are at an
intermediate level now how is the hash
of a block signature generated in
blockchain to generate a digital
signature transaction details are passed
through a one-way hashing function for
example
sha-256 then the output value is passed
through a signature algorithm like ecdsa
with the user's private key then the
encrypted hash along with the other
information such as the hashing
algorithm is called as the digitally
signed document and is called the
digital signature so this is the entire
process of generating a digitally signed
block list down some of the extensively
used cryptographic algorithms these are
the few popular algorithms which are
extensively used sha-256 bitcoin uses it
it has ethereum uses it rsa is one of
the other popular algorithm
blowfish triple des so it's very
important to memorize these algorithms
the names of these algorithms when asked
and shu 256 and it hash are used in two
of the popular public blockchain
networks what is a smart contract and
list some of its application so smart
contracts are self-executing contracts
these are basically digital contracts
which contains the terms and conditions
of an agreement between two parties
between two peers now some of the
applications can be used in
transportation where shipment of goods
can be easily tracked using smart
contracts so as there's a movement of
goods and it is exchanging hands between
different parties there could be need of
a contract and a smart contract between
the parties it is also used in
protecting copyrighted content like
music or books or the literature which
you have written so smart contracts can
protect the ownership rights it can also
be used in insurance it can be used to
identify false claims and prevent
forgeries employment contract smart
contracts can be helpful to facilitate
wage payments and it can be used as a
proof of employment now another
important question what is ethereum
network and how many ethereum networks
are you familiar with ethereum is a
blockchain based distributed computing
platform featuring smart contract
functionality that enable users to
create and deploy their decentralized
applications called dapps there are
three types of network in ethereum live
network the main net then there are
couple of test networks like robston
coven and rink b and then you can also
create your own private network using
ethereum smart contracts are deployed on
the main network they are publicly
available and can be used by others also
test networks allows you to run your
smart contracts on a test net validate
the gas which is being used you can just
use these test networks as the main net
deploy your contracts verify your
decentralized application and then move
on to the main net private networks are
those which are not connected to the
main network which run within the
premises of the organization but carry
the features of an ethereum network now
where do nodes run smart contract code
nodes run smart contract codes on
ethereum virtual machine it is a virtual
machine designed to operate as a runtime
environment for ethereum based smart
contracts evm is operated in a sandbox
environment or isolated from the main
net and it is a perfect testing
environment so you can download the evm
run your smart contact locally in an
isolated manner and once you have tested
and verified it then you can deploy it
on the mainline now very important and a
very good question what is adapt and how
is it different from a normal
application we need to understand these
differences very thoroughly in order to
clear our interview so adap is a
decentralized application which is
deployed using smart contract the
information on a dap is distributed and
shared in a normal application it has a
centralized database which is running on
a centralized server so you have a
single server and a single code which is
maintaining the entire application no
information is shared and it is a single
point of failure a dapp has its backend
code a smart contract which runs on a
decentralized peer-to-peer network in a
normal application it's a typical
computer software application that is
hosted on a central server so if you see
in the differences in the process you
have a front end then in the middle you
have a smart contract which is acting as
the back end code and then the entire
transaction executed on a smart contract
is shared between the blockchain
participants in the p2p network whereas
in a normal application the front end
interacts with a centralized api which
performs basic crud operations create
read update delete on a centralized
database and it is a single copy of the
information name some leading open
source platforms for developing
blockchain applications so ethereum is
one of the popular platforms for
building blockchain-based applications
and it is widely getting adopted aeris
is also used for building
enterprise-based solutions and also some
of the widely used platforms for
building blockchain are listed below
hyperledger multi-chain open chain are
available in the market what is the very
first thing you must specify in a
solidity file now it is necessary to
specify the version number of solidity
at the beginning of a code as it
eliminates incompatibility errors which
can arise while compiling with another
version it is a mandatory clause which
has to be there at the top of any
solidity code which you write and you
need to mention the correct version
number for which you have written the
code now what is the difference between
bitcoin and ethereum and it's a very
important question which i also ask in
lot of interviews and it's important for
you to remember these differences so
bitcoin the concept is purely p2p
currency based transaction but in
ethereum you can do both p2p currency
transaction plus you can deploy smart
contracts bitcoin is primarily working
on proof of work consensus mechanism
ethereum is shifting from proof of work
to proof of stake bitcoin uses sha-256
hashing algorithm whereas ethereum uses
it hash time taken to mine a block
currently on bitcoin is approximately 10
minutes whereas in ethereum it gets
processed in 12 to 15 seconds the reward
for mining on bitcoin as of today is
12.5 bitcoin whereas in ethereum it is
three ethers plus the transaction fees
on bitcoin the transaction fees are
optional whereas in ethereum the fees is
calculated based on the gas which is
being consumed on a smart contract per
transaction value of bitcoin as of 21st
august was captured at
6934 us dollars whereas ethereum stands
at 278 dollars now what is nonce and how
is it used in mining in blockchain
mining is a process to validate
transactions by solving a difficult
mathematical puzzle called proof of work
now proof of work is the process to
determine a number a nonce that is the
number along with the cryptographic hash
algorithm to produce a hash value which
is lower than a predefined target nonce
is a random value which is used to vary
the hash value so that the final hash
value meets the hashing condition so the
nonce is the value which is being
generated by the miner in order to guess
the hash value which should be less than
the target value and then only the miner
can claim the reward for if he's mining
a bitcoin network of 12.5 btc and
ethereum network of three ethers now
let's look at some of the advanced level
questions name the steps that are
involved in a blockchain project
implementation so in a typical
blockchain based project implementation
we start off with requirement
identification we need to understand the
problem and goal we need to identify the
suitable consensus mechanism what is the
most suitable platform which can solve
the problem and then identify the
implementation and deployment cost we
need to give an roi to the client then
we move on to the planning stage in this
step an individual evaluates all the
requirements list them down prioritize
them and decides a suitable blockchain
platform which has to be used to
implement this particular problem then
kicks off the development and
implementation of the project you design
the architecture you design the user
interfaces and start building the apis
and then comes controlling and
monitoring the project you apply the
proof of concept you start off with that
and then start building the application
on top of it and then once the basic
version of the application is available
you start identifying bugs and start
fixing them explain a real life use case
where blockchain is being used so supply
chain is the biggest adopter of
blockchain and as you can see as the raw
material moves is exchanged between
different entities in a supply chain the
traceability of that particular digital
asset which in this case is raw material
is a big case study on blockchain in
supply chain management smart contracts
provide permanent transparency
traceability and validation of
transaction shared by multiple supply
chain partners so at each level each
supply chain partner has to register a
transaction when it receives a product
and then when it passes it on so
basically the purchaser when consuming
the end product can see the entire
journey of the product list and explain
the parts of evm memory so the memory of
an evm is divided into three parts
storage memory and stack storage values
are stored permanently on the blockchain
network and it is extremely expensive so
whenever you will try to modify a
storage based variable you would have to
pay gas for it memory variables are
temporary modifiable storage area it can
be accessed only during the contract
execution and once the execution is
finished the data is wiped off vanished
and lost stack on the other way is a
temporary and a non-modifiable storage
here when the execution is completed the
content is lost so basically memory and
stack are relatively much cheaper than
storage variables now what happens if
the execution of a smart contract costs
more than the specified gas initially
your transaction will be executed but if
the execution of a smart contract costs
more than the specified gas then the
miners will stop validating your
contract the blockchain will record the
transaction as fail as highlighted and
also the user does not get a refund so
it becomes of utmost important that when
you are deploying your smart contract
you do the calculation of the gas
consumption in the most correct fashion
what does the gas usage in a transaction
depend on and how is transaction fee
calculated so gas usage depends upon the
amount of storage you are using if you
are using storage based variables and
the cost of the transactions will be
high the gas will be high and the set of
instruction codes use in a smart
contract basically what operations you
are performing on the storage based
variables either they are costly and if
you are using huge amount of storage
variables then automatically the cost of
your smart contract will keep on
increasing so basically the transaction
fee is calculated in ethers which is
given as the gas price which you have
determined for your smart contract and
multiplied by the gas limit and this is
how your transaction fee is evaluated
now what is fork and what are some of
the types of forking so in simple terms
updating a cryptocurrency protocol or
code is called forking fork implies that
a blockchain splits into two branches
and is done when you want to
modify certain attributes of an existing
blockchain network it can happen when
the participants of the network cannot
come to an agreement with regards to
either the consensus algorithm or they
want new rules for validation so there
are three types of forking heart forking
soft forking and accidental force what
is the difference between proof of work
versus proof of stake and it's a very
important question in blockchain proof
of work is the process of solving a
complex mathematical puzzle called
mining whereas proof of stake is an
alternative proof of work by which the
blockchain aims to achieve distributed
consensus in proof of work probability
of mining a block is based upon the
amount of computational work done by a
miner basically it consumes huge amount
of resources electricity resources and
computational resources of the miner
whereas in proof of take the probability
of validating the block relies upon the
amount of token you own beforehand so
the more the tokens you have the more
the chance you get to validate a block
so basically proof of stock has been
introduced in order to reduce the
pressure on the resources which has been
put by the proof-of-work consensus
algorithm miners spend a lot of
computing power for solving the
cryptographic puzzle along with the
hardware and it's a huge cost so
basically proof of stake was created as
a solution to minimize the use of
expensive resources spent in mining what
is a 51 attack in blockchain 51 attack
refers to a vulnerability where an
individual or group of people can
control the majority of the mining power
or hash rate so basically they can take
over the 50 percent of the blockchain
network this would allow the attackers
to prevent new transactions from being
confirmed further they can double spend
the coins now in 51 attack smaller
cryptocurrencies are primarily being
attacked which does not have a huge
network which has a small consumer base
water function modifiers and solidity
and mentioned the most widely used
modifiers in solidity function modifiers
are used to easily modify behavior of
your smart contract it can be associated
with a function and then whenever a
function is called the modifier is
called before the main function in
simple terms it can build additional
features or apply restrictions on the
function of smart contracts the most
extensively used function modifiers in
solidity are view view functions are
functions that cannot modify the state
of a smart contract they are only read
only functions here is an example you
have a function get simply learn name
and it is having a modifier view which
only returns a value but you are allowed
to use some inbuilt solidity functions
like msg.sender but in case of pure pure
functions are functions that neither
read nor write the state of smart
contracts they return the same result
determined by its input variables so
basically you can even access the
inbuilt functions of solidity so here
you have a function called calculate you
can only use the input variables you
cannot use any of the inbuilt functions
also of solidity now let's take a look
of an example in order to write a crowd
sales smart contract code in solidity
programming language so here in the
example you have a smart contract where
you have defined certain smart contract
variables of solidity like address and
you went now the address function is if
you want to send your token to someone
and your uint is the funding goal in
ethers basically how much amount of
ethers you want to generate in your
crowd sale
project then what is the duration of
your project then cost of each token in
ethers then address of token used as
reward so these are the primary
attributes which you have defined then
you have your public functions which are
defined over here the beneficiary is
successfully sent to the funding goal
the deadline of your crowd sale and the
price now here is your default function
which is defined in a solidity contract
which does not have any function name
and is called by default in your smart
contract if anyone invokes a method in
your smart contract which does not exist
in this function you are making sure
that all the amount which has been
passed to the smart contract is passed
to your address basically you are the
originator of your crowdsale function
crowdsale smart contract so you should
be receiving the amount then in your
crowdsale smart contract you can have a
method which is called as safe
withdrawal and you have appended it with
a modifier called after deadline so
which basically
checks that you can only do a withdrawal
after the deadline has been achieved and
in this function you are checking the
balance then you are withdrawing that
amount from the sender and transferring
it to your own account as the sender has
sent that amount to you so you do the
basic validations whether the sender has
that balance and then you do that
transfer to your account thanks saurabh
i hope this will help you in your
interviews with that we've reached the
end of this complete blockchain tutorial
by simplylearn
i hope you guys enjoyed this video do
like and share it thank you for watching
and stay tuned for more from simplylearn
[Music]